hey what's going on everybody it's bill
bird it's time for the thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast and ah
i'm just checking in on you
checking in to see how your week is
going because i'm that kind of person a
big hollywood phony
because i don't give a [ __ ] really how
you i mean i hope you're having a good
time i just hope you're healthy enough
to make it to my shows in reno in san
jose this weekend there you go that's
the honest thing and um speaking of
honesty i have an amazing guest here
this week um for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast who i got to know
through um this guy that i forget his
name but he had a sweater draped over
his shoulders
like you know like the coming-of-age
dick in the 80s movies
um who let us know
about this amazing young director writer
and all of that we have the wonderful uh
tyler falbo welcome thank you who was on
on the podcast we did a show called
immoral compass uh which is gonna be
debuting november 3rd fifth fifth
on roku roku roku yes
you gotta get this
i'm telling you this kid is a beast he's
soft-spoken
he's humble
this is his second podcast ever he's
gonna be oh you know i don't know what
i'm doing here you know what you're
doing tyler so great i mean how long
have we been we we pitched the show we
got it on quibby oh god yeah that was
we pitched it like 2019
yes got it quibby wanted it
and then pre pandemic we pitched this
thing yeah and then we were supposed to
shoot it
in march of 2020
and then pandemic
that's right yep and then that happened
and then the pandemic happened and then
that
and then cuibi came out after the
pandemic start great timing yes and it
did poorly
and then they luckily said okay we'll go
shoot your show in september
and we did
and then october quibby said well we're
shutting down yeah and then it ended and
it just didn't get going and you know
what's funny was a lot of places i think
during the pandemic
um like streaming and everything because
people were just home they were binge
watching stuff and they just think for
some reason they were the new kids on
the block i think they needed people to
be out to see the billboards
i don't know not like you can't
advertise i don't know what happened
so the friggin show
goes away i was devastated because i
actually do uh i have a little part on
this thing
um playing sort of a guy who peaked in
the early 90s which if you really take
in the details
of how the wardrobe and hair and makeup
how they just absolutely crushed it um
i basically do i was like a wrap around
thing
and to describe what the show is it's
basically um tyler makes these really
short
dark
dark major left turn
short films
that all have like a theme like jealousy
envy uh empathy or something whatever
and it's all built around um i just love
about each one of them it's like there
comes that everybody's sort of normal
when they start
and there's either an event or a
decision
and someone there's a fork in the road
and someone can veer left or they veer
right and your characters always veer
in the direction of excitement we'll say
you know i was thinking uh about because
you know we talked about how like you
know it was great that you're involved
in the show because there is some some
kind of weird similarity
between your comedy and in this show and
it's so different because your economy
is definitely way different than the
show but i think i found out like the
specific thing that reminded me of it
adam lowett our showrunner
uh reminded me of the clip from your
special the black and white one
um where you're doing the bit about the
guy in the helicopter yes yes and and
what was so funny about that bit uh was
not just what happened but you're
describing the pilot sitting there
what's going through his head when he's
watching a guy jump out to commit
suicide yeah just to let people know
there was a guy
who wanted to commit suicide and he
decided to do it by getting a helicopter
ride
you know
though i love the rock star way the guy
went out but also did he need to drag
this guy
into it so this guy actually flew with
the guy
that flew that guy that jumped out and
he never brought it up
which makes him even more badass
and from what i heard the the story was
the guy just kept asking if he could fly
higher can you go a little higher can
this thing go a little higher
and because of where they were there was
an airspace above him probably you know
lax he couldn't go into it
so the guy just like opened the door and
undid his seatbelt and then opened the
door and the pilot tried to grab him now
when you fly a helicopter you can't take
your hands off the controls you know
especially if it's a robinson
um are you gonna start descending
immediately but he grabbed the guy and
the guy
hit him
hit the pilot and then the power was
just like all right [ __ ] it man i'm not
dying too
and the the dude jumped out and uh
landed in the water did not die at first
and then and that's and then yeah i did
a bit on that which i think that would
be a moral conundrum in the show is if
you're the pilot you know what do you do
here do you try and save this guy or or
save your life and then the twist at the
end that happened in your story would
probably happen the show too where the
guy survived
yeah he lived for a minute and you're in
your show the guy would have lived lived
but uh no absolutely dude if you're
flying and someone starts punching you
in the head because they want to jump
out it's like all right jump
i wish you wouldn't do that but uh i'm
feeling good about life and still being
alive and everything so
how did you um
how did you like i don't know how long
have you been making the like making
films and when you started out
because i i start when i started up
stand up i was like totally clean and i
didn't want to offend anybody
because i'd been just getting screamed
at my whole life so i was really on like
my heels and i didn't want to piss off
the headliner and i wanted club owners
well here's a nice wholesome act
that's not gonna you know put any
ripples in the water did you were you
right from the gate were you the sort of
dark or no i mean
i i bet you could guess this but i came
from like a religious background like in
florida like very opposite of what this
is but yeah i know i'm from jacksonville
florida have they seen your films yeah
and i think that's i kind of like you
know like when my grandmother would
watch my shorts like when it hit the
punch line she would just kind of like
shake her head and look down i feel like
that's what inspired me that was your
litmus testing all right i'm on to
something yeah exactly that's just funny
and yeah in high school you know i
always wanted to make like serious
movies like growing up i just loved like
the coen brothers and uh oh they make
some comedy a bunch of comedies too and
like paul tom sanderson movies and i
always wanted to make like that kind of
stuff but whenever i was coming up with
ideas i would always like figure out
some weird [ __ ] up direction it would
go in and it would not be what i wanted
to do but it just naturally always
happened that way
and i just was like oh i should lean
into this this is better than what i was
gonna make anyway but what i liked is i
couldn't guess the ending it was always
just like somebody did something and uh
or you know what i kind of you put
yourself
in in the place of the character a lot
where you're just going like all right
what would i if i just did that would i
fess up to it would i try to get out of
it
and um
i can't stress enough i i just hope
people you know are going to flock to
this thing because
the casting that we got on this you have
one where i think these two guys should
do a movie just the way they look
together on screen we have one
of the short films that stars vince
vaughn and bobby lee and just seeing the
two of them together they're both like
genius comedic actors and one guy's
what's vince six
five yeah and then bobby's like five
what six or seven i hope
no no he's gotta be
no but i mean for me that was like you
know that's part of the um
this i don't wanna give anything away
but it is important that they were these
size differences and uh
and
that was just like unbelievable that
they were both willing to do that one i
was i had no idea i was gonna get those
guys like those like heavyweights yeah i
mean i i
well you know what it is there's so much
uh
you know there's a lot of material out
there but i just don't think there's
really
great material and what sold it was what
you wrote and then you had those
those other ones the guy helping his
girlfriend move in and
all the stuff that happens in that one
this is gonna be such a difficult show
to talk about because
those are all the surprises i don't want
to give it away but like al madrigal's
in one maryland uh rice cubs in another
uh
i host them sort of the uh what were
they what were they calling me the uh oh
they yeah in the interview the the
downer rod sterling downer rod sterling
yeah
i'll tell you which i love that because
that i mean that is the kind of thing we
were going for is it like someone to
bring the whole show together i mean you
know it gets a little more involved as
we go on but yeah like your character's
point of view really drives everything
in the show well if we do us if we were
lucky enough to get another season of
this uh i have more ideas
of where i want to take that guy i i
have a couple ideas too because it's
like that guy we could go further with
him or it's like what if you're another
guy
like just complete like we go in a
different direction you do that same
it's the same purpose but like you're
not rick anymore you're
you know steven you know what i like
about that is that's like old school tv
where
by the time i came around and was
attempting to act
like if you did a guest star on a show
you were done
yeah so you had to make sure that like
you know there was a couple i mean i
booked something on jag and my my agent
was just like it's only like two lines
dude they're not going to bring you back
so like so we waited out for a better
part i never got another i never got to
wear the navy whites right so but back
in the day like you if you did a show
and they liked you you could come back
a number of times like i've been binge
watching uh the untouchables and the
recently uh passed away the late great
ed asner he was incredible he did like
three or four of those
gavin mccloud
did a couple lee marvin did two
um there was a number they would you
became like this this guy that they um
they just believed in and it was just
like you could be a you could be a
character actor like and just keep doing
different characters and then somewhere
along the line
um
i guess it became kind of funny to
people as they got educated to tv like
you know like how can you keep bringing
that guy back just because he's got a
mustache it's like that guy was running
a car wash
you know last season and this season
he's you know he's shooting a machine
gun but i just think back then it wasn't
uh everyone was just so s like so
psyched to have a tv which i you know if
all of a sudden you could watch the
radio but um i kind of like that idea
did you watch did you like uh once upon
a time in hollywood
oh my god are you kidding me
i mean i love that movie i actually own
it on dvd i got i don't know i got a
screener and i won't throw that out even
though my [ __ ] tv doesn't recognize
my dvd player so i got to get an
external one and i just
like i i could talk forever about that
movie i went to tarantino's movie
theater and watched it oh me too you
know what there's a very subtle thing in
that movie
that you watch it like three times
you'll pick up on it no one ever says
hippie it's always [ __ ] hippie
the whole movie
is [ __ ] hippies and i just love like
my whole life the manson family
was so like uh
just propped up on this oh my god they
were so demonic and they were terrifying
like oh my god like who are you know i
know what they did was terrifying and he
reduced them
to just a bunch of lazy [ __ ] white
kids who didn't want to get jobs
who actually were fans of movies and tv
because you know they geek out when they
meet leonardo's character
in the end and they he just reduced them
to what they were a bunch of dumb
jerk-offs that did horrible [ __ ]
things
to a wonderful industry that makes all
this entertainment you know for people
to watch and uh
the cars in it
um you know
oh my god lee i think that was
leonardo's best performance that little
stammer that he had and how he just
hated himself like he did that you could
just see like um how
that probably drove him
you know he probably got made fun of as
a kid he hated himself that's the best
part in the movie to me i mean other
than the ending but uh you know his
little arc of like not being able to get
his lines right and then coming back in
this triumphant thing of him just doing
the performance right but that was the
whole reason i brought it up was that uh
that movie kind of gave you know i'm way
younger and i've seen old reruns of
stuff but like the whole world of
you know guest spots on classic tv shows
and they they put him they wanted to put
him in the huge mustache and the beer
they didn't want him to look like you
know rick dalton who was famous from the
other show they don't you know the
director's like i don't want them to see
you right you know so they put them in
all this makeup and stuff which is
kind of what we kind of wanted to do
with you yeah yeah i'm
i had a great time
a really great time doing that and i'm
you know dude i'm really early on with
like acting learning how to do it so
each time i just approaching it like
comedy each time i try to get a little
bit better
sometimes i try something and it doesn't
work you know people make fun of me on
the internet i don't give a [ __ ] because
it's just like okay so i bombed that
part of it bombed but you know you just
got to kind of
keep moving forward oh dude that thing
where leonardo when he's
he he's not in it
when they're doing that take and they
he's trying to make those mess and stuff
like and it's just like i watched that
and as much as i wanted to laugh it
actually
was really embarrassing because i was
like i've done that
they didn't use the take i hope but like
you just get into that thing of like i'm
not in this i'm not in this do something
interesting you know you make like some
weird face or anything just the way
that that whole thing was played and um
i still this day anytime i get on the
101 and that exit every time i think of
brad pitt driving that white cadillac
every single
time and um so anyway
roku november 5th is this show i'm just
going to keep saying that um oh speaking
of your look uh i never told you this
like a couple weeks ago we had a little
like meeting about the press stuff and
the people that were doing the the
poster they're doing like the photoshop
on
the like key art and stuff
they're like so like do you know like
you know like bill's hair like i don't
know if it's a decision but like it
doesn't look that good like it looks
like bad hair plugs
like dude do you want us to photoshop
that and i'm like no no that's what it's
supposed to look like why would they
think that i would do that i thought
you'd be like self-conscious about look
like having the bad ear plugs no that
was the thing this guy like
we did all these little things i don't
want to give too much but we did all of
these little things these little nods
and okay we'll talk about the bad hair
pockets
because the the this photo will be like
this one
so they'll know what you look like okay
so what i loved
you know uh the hair plugs
from the 90s those ones uh which weren't
the original ones because i know
i think elton john got one of the
original hair transplants and his scalp
is just all scarred up like what
whatever the hell they did to him
but after that then they had those ones
that i was everyone used to call ant
legs
and for some reason i don't know if it
was super painful there were so many
people that i saw
on the subway when i was in new york in
the 90s they would be sitting down and
they would just get one row of them
and then they would grow them out and
they would comb it back
and it just you could see like a dot
where they put it in and it just sort of
never faded or went away and it made
like your eyes water
so um
i feel like when you see those things
which i actually feel like they went
away like the [ __ ] stamp you know now
that you can
get rid of a tattoo like you never see a
[ __ ] stamp plus the women who got them
are you know of a certain age so maybe
they don't show them off but
um i feel like all of those things went
away but like this guy with like
you know those hair plugs the the tribal
table hair plugs right they look like
that's what people were worried that we
actually did it on accident it's like no
people looked like that yeah no they had
that and then a lot of guys had that
tribal tattoo that was a big white guy
thing to get like he was somehow
connected to uh
you know uh some new zealand
you know whatever that sick song is that
they they sing you ever see that thing
before they play rugby oh yeah or they
do the dance too whatever the hell that
thing is that's just like all right
we're not winning this game yeah i can't
tell about this game is over like my
first instinct would be to laugh at it
but if i was standing there in front of
those guys i'd be terrified i think
oh no i would not be laughing those
those guys are like
yeah that's beyond breaking those guys
would break your femur like whatever the
biggest bone like those guys just trying
to tackle them it's just like a bunch of
[ __ ]
lawrence taylors and earl campbell's
like totally amped up and it's like
regular season games too so um
anyway do you as it's just a you know
out of curiosity for like if this thing
gets picked up which i don't know why it
wouldn't do it i mean it really is it's
one of the most proud thing that i've
been a part of that we've we've produced
here
um
as far as like the tv shows
you guys were really instrumental in
this atc like that was huge getting all
the people involved and that entire
process was crucial yeah what did we do
we just
we pitched the show you made it but i
appreciate that but if you do like a
season two do you have like
ideas and all of that stuff i've got a
couple and there's a couple from season
one that like we couldn't do for budget
reasons or whatever that uh that maybe
we now we can figure it out but there's
like there's definitely some stuff there
that i'm excited to jump back into and
also you know we had a writer's room for
the first one so we would have another
one we had like i think about eight like
great
writers that were like pitching ideas
you know we made this show has 20
sketches in it
and it doesn't seem like that many but
it was a nightmare to to like get them
all in this show so you got some
leftover tracks we have a little bit
yeah
a little bit
all right it's headspace everybody you
know what the [ __ ] just what was that
selling somebody farted over there all
right it's headspace everybody
wouldn't it be great if there were a pod
pocket-sized guide that help you sleep
focused act and be better i'm hearing
all kinds of noise
paul will you stop [ __ ] drinking your
slub
jesus christ look at the guy he's got he
looks like a [ __ ] wide receiver how
many chains you got now all right
all right
yeah i just hit mute paul all right it's
head space everybody
you know wouldn't it be great if there
were a pocket-sized guide that helped
you sleep
focus act and be better well there is
and if you have just 10 minutes
headspace can change your life headspace
is your daily dose of mindfulness in the
form of guided meditations in an easy to
use app headspace is one of the only
meditation apps advancing the field of
mindfulness and meditation through
clinically validated research
so whatever the situation head spates
really can help you feel better
overwhelmed headspace has a three-minute
sos i can't do it the grocery store
picking up the kids you can just sit
there breathing in your suv
meditation for you my heated seat is on
too hot and i can't get it to go back
down
need some help falling asleep oh god she
won't quit nagging me headspace as a
wind-down session their members swear by
how to tune out your wife
they got it no kidding and for parents
headspace has even morning meditations
you can do with your kids so you don't
put them in your car and drive them into
a lake
and then blame a black guy remember that
white checker did that the original
karen of the 2000's headspace's approach
to mindfulness can redrew stress improve
sleep boost focus and increase your
overall sense of well-being headspace is
backed by over 25 published studies
not the ones that people are just
talking [ __ ] about in the bar these are
actually published on its benefits 600
000 5-star reviews over 60 million
downloads 60 million headspace fans
can't be wrong headspace makes it easy
for you to build a life-changing
meditation practice with your
mindfulness that works for you on your
schedule anytime anywhere you deserve a
happier
you've you so you deserve to feel
happier and head space is meditation
made simple go to headspace.com burr
that's headspace.com
for a free one month trial with access
to headspace full library of meditations
for every situation
this is the best deal offered right now
head to head space man
headspace dot com slash burr today head
h-e-a-d space
s-p-a-c-e dot com
b-u-r-r today you know would be great uh
is uh
there's got to be something in like the
pandemic
and everybody feeling like whatever side
they're on mask getting vacs no mass not
getting fast like
like uh everybody just thinks they're so
[ __ ] right and there's really like an
argument
you know why would you trust big
pharmaceutical companies i mean they
started basically a [ __ ] nationwide
heroin epidemic and killed a bunch of
people's kids
but i mean like a lot of athletes a lot
of athletes became like heroin addicts
because they were given a basically
synthetic uh heroin right and then you
had um
you know and then the other side of not
listening to doctors and listening to
your friends or becoming your own yeah
sort of uh lab technician i'm gonna go
on webmd and diagnose myself with no
[ __ ] background so i just figure both
of those
are kind of wide open um yeah i would
like to come up with an idea that would
make both sides angry you know it's like
both sides they're watching the sketch
are like wait what like what see there
you go that's that's how i that's what i
do
like when i go you know like last night
i was making fun of uh
the way liberals trash uh red states i
was down at largo and i was just
trashing them
um because i was talking about the
tomahawk chop
and like how can they do that how can
they keep doing that it's just like
well why would they show empathy when
northern whites have not shown empathy
towards southern whites
since we're still not over the civil war
right
um whether we realize it or not the [ __ ]
that we say like you know if you're
going to treat them like [ __ ] then it
just [ __ ] runs downhill
so that was sort of the bit
and um but then if i go to uh
like you know red states you know i talk
about their four-wheelers
and you know their buddy and whoever and
blah blah i've seen both sides of that
from you i i'm from jacksonville
i went to a show like a long time ago in
jacksonville comedy zone you were at
that place yeah my friend like is a was
a com my friend forest does did stand up
all the time there basically and uh and
al madrigal has some stories about that
place too um but i don't want to speak
too much about that but that place was
wild you stayed it was uh one of those
motels like the radisson attache or
ramada in or i don't know what it was
yeah your door to your hotel room opens
up to outside which is so [ __ ]
terrifying that is basically like dude
you're on your own
yeah i i never did i did stand up twice
in my life because my friends did it it
was not for me but i was around that
whole like community and the whole like
if you want to be a comic you have to
pay to go to this class at the comedy
zone that's run by the guy that runs the
comedy zone it's just like a scam like
it
i felt like it was like a cult right i
don't know anyway yeah that that yeah
that was uh a result of the 80s
when the in the 80s like all of these
people came through and as it exploded
so many people by so many people i mean
like half a dozen or a dozen of them
um
became these big like sitcoms stars and
then they're
you know a lot of guys got deals a lot
of people got like you know it maybe got
picked up and it went a few weeks but
like
they looked at everybody as though they
were a potential tim allen roseanne
seinfeld
ray romano all of these guys that came
through and then ended up being worth
hundreds of millions of dollars and they
wanted a piece of it so
they would start these things dude all
of a sudden comedy club owners when i
came in
comedy club owners wanted to start
becoming managers they wanted to manage
you
and then they would sort of
um position you getting your spots
you know if i sign with them i'll get
spots then you had to play the game of
like yeah
yeah like you know who i want to guide
my career a club owner
because who knows more about putting
together a sitcom deal than a club owner
right and it was just like and i saw
people like
get involved in like those relationships
and then like the most awkward part was
when they started getting heat
and and the club owners started [ __ ]
up because they didn't know what they
were doing and they're learning with
your career by making mistakes when they
had to walk away it was always [ __ ] that
guy or [ __ ] that that woman she's never
working at this club again that happened
a lot
when i was coming up yeah um
yeah no it seems like like a weird
pyramid scheme like thing that is now
whatever the point is sort of normal
it's kind of what happens anytime
there's money involved uh people want
to get everybody wants to start wetting
their beak at first nobody gives a [ __ ]
then all of a sudden it's like holy [ __ ]
you know it's like when comics started
doing like uh
podcasts nobody gave a [ __ ] uh it's a
stupid little promotional tool then all
of a sudden people started making money
on it and then all of a sudden agencies
are like we're going to start our own
podcast network and we're going to own
50 of your podcasts like that's what it
is
that also reminds me of the whole quivi
the failure thing was that you know you
were one of the maybe the first comic
ever to do a netflix special right
no no um i was one of the first
that had one on comedy central that then
went to netflix because
i used to hang in new york
uh
with joe derosa you know back in the day
right um
you know before i moved out here we used
to hang out and one of the things was he
got he had netflix when you when they
delivered movies yeah and then he got it
he had it on his tv because he's like a
huge huge film guy
and
we used to sit there and watch
the stand-up specials and they at that
point just wanted anything that they
could get on there and they had some
[ __ ] brutal
brutally awful like i don't even know
where they got these because at that
point netflix was the last option
where now they're the first option like
i remember
when um
in the late 2000s being brought on stage
at the improv
and one of the things i said you might
have seen is special on netflix and it
would get an audible laugh if you can
[ __ ] believe it they would laugh
because they were like oh you mean that
[ __ ]
blockbuster postmate thing i mean
postmates didn't exist but like they
yeah they were kind of considered
like uh like a joke you know so uh you
were well you were definitely at the
front of that right yeah
and then on but beyond that you're the
one the first to do a podcast like
there's a bunch of guys at the beginning
but you were in earl you know before
this crazy podcast craze you're in and
then i saw those things and i'm like oh
and we're going quibby this is the new
this is the next story no i know i'm
like oh perfect
i know that happened so you know cause
bobby kelly was the one who got me to do
a podcast accidentally and it was back
when we were still on myspace and he was
just like dude you know dude you just
you call up this number dude you talk to
your fans it's a great way to promote
yourself dude
check it out you get this you flip that
boom and he did the whole thing so i was
like all right so i started doing it
that way but bobby also told me to get a
mini disc player
telling me that this is and i still have
it with the little t microphone and i
have sets on it i can't find the charger
um so you know you win some and you lose
something when you're on like the
forefront and i thought you know
you know quibby was you know had as good
a shot as anything and god knows that
the people that they had over there they
had some heavy hitters you know that had
done all of this other stuff but um
anyway i'm i'm so happy that
that people are going to see this show
dude because i think you really are so
unique and so talented
and the way you put this thing together
and um the people that you know
came on all and did you did these little
shorts with you all had the best time
and were thrilled and the trailer you
made like i was showing it to people
like dude this looks cinematic
like i want to see this movie so um
awesome
yeah so anyway so uh is there anything
else you want to propose we got the
number one thing is immoral compass is
what it's called everybody
november uh
november 5th
uh
2021 the day after the election it was
was yesterday the big tuesday whatever
the hell it was um
yeah super tuesday you got to watch this
thing because i have promoted so many
things
and the the the the critic that you get
interviewed by is just like oh yeah so
what was it like to work with so and so
what do you feel about your character do
you like making movies or whatever this
one both critics were like oh my god i
was watching this thing and i was like
no way where the [ __ ] is this going like
there was an audible excitement from
critics
which is uh you know
yes that's all you want so um i know uh
you got anything else that you want to
promote all my eggs are in this basket
this is all i got if it fails i'm done
back to jackson
um i keep i've been wanting to ask you
the whole time we'll do one quick last
one here
what uh what religion were you brought
up in and at what point did you
i don't know if you've broken away you
know you can assume correctly
okay um
i think um
uh yeah i'm not gonna
all right so i'm not asking you to trash
it i'm just
interested because i was raised catholic
i got away from it and now that i'm
older
i'm feeling myself gravitating to
wanting to believe
in something but it's hard
and not just to save my own ass we
should do astrology that's what
everyone's doing now
what's the next i know hitler did
astrology and that's why he lost the war
i was danny got he got stretched out he
got he was too thin you know yeah that
was the issue that had been it um he was
also a private
was he he was a private in the army and
then he started this group
you know what i mean and then they uh
called the nazis i know if you i like
what i just said i started this group
like never heard of it and then so they
had a private guy who never raised
higher than a private
and he he [ __ ] uh was now running
your country and he was into astrology
that's why he was like a player's coach
believe it or not a lot of people don't
know he was a player's coach where he
got gassed in world war one so he made
sure all of their bunkers had a shower
that if he got gas you could shower
yourself off oh you know oh i imagine
him more of a belichick type but he and
you would right um you would but he
actually cared about his messed up
soldiers wow obviously had blue eyes and
blonde hair i'm surprised no one's made
him well i'm not surprised but someone
should make a movie just it's about just
his failed art career it's just like
that led to it you know it's like the
whole movie is him trying to be an
artist and at the end he just makes that
turn yeah and you're like oh no
that sounds like one of your shorts i
used to do a bit about that if somebody
could just have encouraged him
[Laughter]
and just kept him on the easel
like what what you know
i don't know it's
it's true i mean yeah that's uh
because the van gogh movie i don't we
don't have to go into that but there's a
van gogh movie that basically he was
trashed his whole life and he still went
for it mm-hmm but man
if he doesn't people didn't like his
stuff his whole life oh man it was it
was really brutal it was like the uh
there's a movie with william to foe
that's really good called at eternity's
gate and it's kind of like about his
life because he wasn't famous for
painting at all until after he died like
that happens with a lot of artists but
like that one like there's like a scene
where like he's like he's like treated
as like a freak like a like mental issue
he thinks he's good at painting but he
did have some mental i know he had a big
time booze hound yeah he had a lot of
issues actually but he cut his ear off
yeah i mean that wasn't over a woman
though i heard he pulled the blade on
his roommate
and then he turned it on himself
i wonder what the real story is
because there's like a bunch probably
was shit-faced painting and fell into
his easel and when it collapsed it
knocked off his ear and then i think
people who wanted to make you know who
found his paintings because i watched a
documentary
on uh how they prop up that market and
how this you know like every single
market there's like five four or five
major players and they sort of move the
needle
and how they decide uh what is worth
something and what isn't and blah blah
blah blah i you know i'm not big i
believe was this is a shocker not big in
the art world but i actually really like
his stuff
and when i was in where is he from is it
is it holland or is it uh i feel bad not
seeing the movie but it was in he was in
spain for a lot of it i think was in
paris twice yeah but there's there's
some museum
denmark maybe i was somewhere and i
actually went and i saw his original
work like a lot of them yeah and i i
really there was something about like i
like looking at stuff that looks like
stuff right like i get a little bit in
like that that basquiat stuff you yeah
that's how you say his name i i
look at it i ki i kind of get it it's
like cool or whatever but uh
i don't know when it just starts being
like it looks like a five-year-old just
did it
all right am i supposed to uh yeah
that's an entire that's an entire road
to go down but anyway the point was that
we were talking about religion yeah i
don't know what what religion what
religion were you brought up in i'm
really like sidestepping this question
um i was you don't have to answer no i
will i know i will i was i was raised
really christian but it was
non-denominational my grandmother was
one of the uh like billy graham like
went to his like
that was the [ __ ] i actually went to i i
i got like uh born again when i was like
10 years old in uh the jacksonville
jaguars arena like stadium with billy
graham yeah no that's like seeing
zeppelin he's like the zeppelin of
preachers and that guy was just like you
saw billy graham live i know i wish i
appreciated it more at the time um yeah
went down on the field did the whole
thing dude that guy was doing stadiums i
mean i know he was like [ __ ] you two
of like
i priests you got just as an entertainer
you know every weekend it's like am i
gonna move tickets that guy was just
like i wonder if he had to do like an
extra sermon you know hey you're trying
to go up north they're not buying this
jesus [ __ ] you got to do an extra
do an extra sermon to try and promote
this oh man yeah i mean
yeah that was crazy um but
i mean i was pretty like christian
religious like uh throughout my middle
school and then high school
i think it was like i started to get
into comedy and
uh like like watching stand-up and
movies and stuff and
it like was going against what they were
talking about but i'm like i kind of
like this more and then but i was still
trying to figure out a way not to curse
you know i didn't like curse until like
senior high school but i was still
making weird like stuff
and then it just like it must been the
catholic school girl thing like as soon
as i was like you know it's not for me
immediately it's like people like
getting calmed on or something like you
know it's like something terrible
um
well that's what happens when you when
you like how many times can you see that
somebody with an overbearing oppressed
childhood becomes like a [ __ ] banshee
whenever if that's i don't know what
that term means at this point every
[ __ ] term you use now you're like
wait a minute is that like a [ __ ]
yeah something you shouldn't say um
yeah like jim morrison you know had a
real like you know yeah it was a
military brat really like oh it was oh i
didn't know that yeah yes sir no sir you
know this is how you make the bed and
all of that i mean i think that's that's
kind of like uh what i was seeing about
that it's really uh
so it's kind of good to you know yeah i
always let him run a little bit let
hitler paint a little more well scorsese
was gonna be a priest like that was a
part of his his like upbringing he's
like really gonna go into the priesthood
and then he makes like good fellas i
think there's a lot of like back then
they they so scared the [ __ ] out of
people about going to hell that i think
there was mothers that wanted
one of their kids to be a priest
as like collateral for some of the other
[ __ ] they did so they could get into
heaven and then there was another big
thing back then you know you know you
weren't allowed to be gay openly yeah so
that was a place where gay people could
go and hide and stuff it's so [ __ ]
ridiculous that you just can't be who
you are but that's the way it was um but
i was listening uh about a couple years
ago i listened to lenny bruce at
carnegie hall starts off a little you
know
slow but once he gets going like how
contemporary it still is and he does
this whole bit talking about
homosexuality
and like you can't believe
like
i mean the way they made it seem like
back then it was like the dark ages and
stuff like that as far as people being
accepting
of gay people but like the way he talked
about it and the way people were
laughing it was like oh everybody knew
everybody knew
it i mean it was also manhattan so
manhattan was always ahead of the curve
socially when it came to [ __ ] like that
but like
they were just talking about like uh
he was just making references to that
uncle you know and this is uh one of his
buddies he's always hanging out i can't
remember how he put it in the way people
were laughing like everybody like just
sort of uh
sort of knew so i don't know i was
imagining him as like one of those like
i don't know what it was really like but
like to go see lenny bruce you had to
like go through a speakeasy or something
you know like it wasn't like like
acceptable like was he i don't know much
about you know i've heard like his
comedy and stuff but like was he doing
like late night shows and stuff or is he
allowed you know i know he he did a lot
of shows like in the village there was
like the whole uh
there was a whole like beat poet things
was going on the sort of the folk thing
you know dylan and those guys i think
were a little bit after him
but and but i think there was a lot of
uh
like
sort of over like those shows back when
there was more of a variety show like
the [ __ ] that was on tv you know
spinning plates and a ventriloquist and
then somebody comes out and sings a song
or whatever i think that there was shows
like a poet a comedian a band would come
out and play it was just live
entertainment
and uh i know that a young george carlin
used to watch lenny down in the the
village but it seems like the time to
see him
was before i think like the authorities
sort of broke him where he was like just
reading about his trial
and he sort of got like obsessed with
that the way they were [ __ ] with them
and everything uh but before then when
he was just up there
just talking
um
you know if you can get your hands on
like bootleg stuff it's really really
incredible like he had dude he had a
[ __ ] bit
like six months
recorded
six months after the kennedy
assassination doing a bit
because like the whole story was that
jackie kennedy was trying to grab a
secret service person to help
her husband out and he was like no she
was trying to save her own ass
and then listening to people laughing at
that
because i really think that there's this
whole perception of back then if you
watch the tv you know the mickey mouse
club and howdy duty show and all that
you think that these people
didn't
you know didn't look at this stuff
critically like this is [ __ ] yeah i
always tell this story it reminds me a
long time ago i was taking drum lessons
from this guy who called himself the
last of the great armenian trap drummers
in brockton massachusetts it was a great
music store which i hope is still there
i used to take drum lessons from this
guy this guy was in his 70s that
so let's see it was the 1990s
so what is that he was born in the 20s
and he was telling me man he goes i used
to bang this broad and as i said it was
down the boston commons he goes i used
to bang this broad up against the tree
during my lunch hour that the boss is
coming i i had this look on my face like
like i couldn't believe it and he just
laughed and he goes let me tell you
something kid
because i said you did that he goes let
me tell you something kid he goes every
generation thinks they're the first one
that ever [ __ ]
now here's a paradiddle
um so anyway the name of the show we got
to wrap this up here uh and then we got
before we wrap uh
this up once again it's immoral compass
november 5th on roku you know there's so
much stuff out there that is forgettable
this is memorable this is you're such a
talented
uh guy man and i'm so psyched to be in
business with you uh that you you came
over here to do something with all
things comedy because uh you you really
made us look good with what you made
here and um for those people listening
tyler fabo is his name we got the uh the
bet mgm um
picks of the week for you football fans
coming up next
what's up everybody we are back for the
nfl week number eight preview brought to
you
by bet mgm
uh we'll be using the greatest lines out
there the bet mgm lines to make all of
our picks and we'll have special offers
for our listeners each week if you
haven't signed up for bet mgm yet
use bonus code b-u-r-r fur could not be
easier b-u-r-r
you'll get a hundred dollars free after
placing your first bet here's how it
works you download the bet mgm app and
you sign up using bonus code bur b-u-r-r
place your first dollar bet my uh dollar
money line bet on any game you'll
receive a hundred dollars in free bets
immediately after placing your bet
regardless of the outcome it's that
simple just make sure you use bonus code
b-u-r-r that's bur b-u-r-r when you sign
up
now
getting into this week uh
getting into this week here we made some
people some money we made some people
some money oh you're making people
monday
monday you are making people money i
don't know how i'm going to catch up
with a man who doesn't lose
i go three and one he goes three and one
i go two and two
i [ __ ] i drop a game paul versi
is on point and last week if you watched
what part of his monday night let the
monday and that special part of his bet
was he he made the bold
dare i say arrogant statement
that patrick mahomes the great pain do
it sideways i've never seen that before
was gonna throw an interception
and if we have the highlights i was
shaking my head paul i thought she lost
your mind
i thought she had so many [ __ ] chains
around your neck your head was up your
ass i didn't think it was gonna happen
what does patrick mahomes do
he throws a pic and i said paul if
patrick of holmes
throws an interception on monday night
football on one of the biggest stages in
regular season
and the regular season i would sing you
i said connie francis it's actually
brenda lee i would sing you i'm sorry
and paul i am a man of my word
so here we go i'm going to sing this now
we don't have the music so i'm just
going to sing it i'm sorry
so
sorry
that i was
such a fool
i didn't know
monday night football could be so cruel
oh paul versi
you tell me
mistakes
are part of
being young
i hate to sing that line that line's
just funny paul i am sorry
i mean paul like you know you started
hot i thought you were gonna cool off
the end of september it didn't happen
i'm like you know paul's you know
he's gonna pull a hammy you know
mid-october didn't happen we are now
into november paul
the holiday season has begun
and this is just like at some point you
just have to admit paul versus he's a
good team
after all of these years of dwelling in
the cellar
of the nfc east
[Laughter]
paul verzi has learned some things paul
has taken points
paul he's he's in tune with his vibe i i
i don't see myself catching you paul i'm
not
trying to jinx you here i'm just being
[ __ ] honest um i went two and two
last week i got to tell you though
that thing that just looked like such an
obvious gift last week was the one good
thing that i did make was the um
the seattle seahawks against the
jacksonville jaguars they were given
like was it four and a half and or five
at home
and uh they went like 38 to [ __ ]
three or something
and i had one other one
but the the bills [ __ ] me over man
they covered
the last goddamn minute i was i was
going i was trying to stay in in in in
step with paul versey 3-1 i'm two and
two so i think i'm like 500 for the year
and with emily's yeah you're like one
game over 500. one game over one game
over 500 picking against the spread paul
do you see this on tv they they just
picked the money line i have one game
over 500 in november picking against the
spread and i am still two games behind
paul versus like when you win a hundred
games and so [ __ ] [ __ ] team wins 120
no but that's wrong because i'm two
games yeah
yeah so i got to be 500 yeah you're 500
or one game below i got to re-tally it
up after this week but yeah that's
i can't believe i'm 500. i thought i've
had a lot of one and one below i think
paul's too overwhelmed oh i got to look
here
listen we are better than most people
doing this including espn analysts and
that's just a statistical fact all right
we're doing great we're making people
money we're using [ __ ] bed mgm they
know it you [ __ ] know it we almost
gave them a monday night special three
weeks in a row we finally came through
keep riding the train
keep riding the anything better [ __ ]
training i'm i'm riding your coattails
cause you're the one the the
patrick mahomes i'll tell you paul your
picks on the monday night special
they're as great as our merch
how do you like that
our merch is murdering it but dude i'm
going to tell you this right now and you
saw this look at this soft
the chiefs are a bad football team the
chiefs [ __ ] stink dude they stink on
so many different levels and it's weird
because they kind of have the same
personnel but he's not finding anybody
open he's missing passes down field this
guy was breaking down how his legwork is
all over the place something's wrong
dude i don't know if the kid's hurt one
of my that's what my brother said he
goes i think he's hurt i was like that's
a great call i didn't think that but i
also think dude they're not a bad
football team for kansas city they're
bad
i mean you know what are they five and
three five and three is [ __ ] terrible
for them or whatever they are five and
four or something i mean what what week
we're on
yeah i think they're like four and i
think they're like a game under 500 but
like they yeah they're bad for what they
should be i guess but i think he's hurt
i think he can't do certain things with
his i think he's hurt that's the only
explanation i have hey what do i know
though but hey he
oh my you know
but he does seem to be moving fine
in the pocket from what i've seen paul
as a 53 year old white male comedian i
think the man is uh moving he moves
better than i do on stage
when i hit the big stage paul you know
when i go over to uh
fuddruckers to do a set in their [ __ ]
function room
yeah it's funny how we're [ __ ]
comedians and this guy's an elite
athlete in the nfl and we're going this
guy's legs this guy's not
these guys are terrible they run 440s
you know
i don't run a 480.
no i'm sorry i'm going the wrong way i
don't run it i i added yards rather than
time i don't run a 10 40. after he threw
the pick somebody somebody tweeted uh
hey paul i think things are a little
worse at home than you thought they were
remember you said last week you said you
heard that there was some some [ __ ]
going on i didn't get that
wow
oh the rumors the rumor mills
aaron rodgers not playing this week
because he tested positive for covet and
then they found out that he lied when he
was asked if he was vaccinated he said
yes they found out today that he was not
vaccinated and he tested positive so he
will not be playing against the chiefs
next week
so is he having a midlife crisis
something dude got the long
i own you guys i still own you guys
i like dude i'm telling you i like the
new aaron rodgers
the old aaron rodgers where he was just
whatever you want i'm gonna do it this
guy he's he's had enough and he's not
taking anymore i'm not getting the
vaccine
if i own you i'm gonna [ __ ] say i own
you
i don't know paul i like the new laurel
canyon
singer songwriter aaron aaron rodgers
requested some of his paycheck in
bitcoin he's gonna you're gonna see that
guy on a [ __ ] surfboard in malibu all
over the paper soon and then it's over
as soon as that guy gets on a surfboard
it's over
no he's gonna win
he's going ken stabler ken stabler was
like that
when the coach was going like hey hey
ken you got to try to get more sleep
before the game he's like coach how many
hours sleep do you need to play three
hours of football
that's great
i like it aaron rodgers is reminding me
of quarterbacks in the 70s
okay i'm sick of all these [ __ ] guys
you know just sitting there eating their
goddamn whatever the [ __ ] they're
they're beet juice and all of that [ __ ]
i like it i like a guy that goes a
little rogue i want to see a quarterback
that has a coors light at halftime
you know i want to see somebody going
old school little john elway have a
cigarette and a [ __ ]
you know bud light or whatever he used
to do
during halftime you know who's that guy
bobby lane bobby lane would come in they
would knock him out and be like jesus
christ man is that from last night i
know i had a couple of pops at halftime
the good old days we got listen we i
just saw these lines and you bill you
get first pick because it's an odd week
it's week nine so it is your
first pick i'm an odd guy i am an odd
guy i am gonna take the uh
let's see i'm gonna take the chargers uh
in philadelphia given one and a half um
i think the charges are coming off a
loss paul
uh the eagles i think they're better
than people you know thought they were
going to be the beginning part of the
year but i just feel like this is a game
that eagles the eagles lose
and makes their fan base do something
crazy the holidays are here
something has to happen somebody's going
to throw a [ __ ] turkey or do
something [ __ ] nuts that has to do
with the holidays to add to the legend
of the behavior of uh philadelphia fans
so i like the chargers
on the road paul
going in
to the the hostile confines but like you
know i think
veteran stadium was way more hostile
when you're basically playing on cement
now i think they have a nice field
you know that's who i like i like the
charges
given one and a half
i like that pick especially off of a
loss all right my first pick i'm gonna
go
kansas city
no no i'm sorry i'm gonna go cincinnati
bengals at home against the browns i
think the browns are finito i think the
browns are done
i like that the bengals had that game
against the the jets the banks
the bengals are a girl group paul
it's bengals the bangles
are like our lips are sealed
bengals
that's actually the go-go's the go-go
sorry i'm so sorry to be there what are
the bangles i walked like an egyptian
yeah yeah eternal flame it's just
another manic monday whoa
wish it was a sunday whoa i [ __ ] love
that bed
don't disrespect the bangles this is the
didn't prince write that one the bengals
yeah prince wrote manic monday ah why'd
you have to take the shine off it
all right
i'm gonna take cincinnati sunday
at home minus three against the browns i
think joe burrow and them have a big
bounce back week after what went on with
the jets and that's my homecoming theory
right there smack in the face i love
that
all right paul i got one for you i'm
gonna bet on the dolphins again after
they lost me money last week
uh
they got a win by s they got to win by
seven they're giving six and a half over
houston who i just kept saying they
can't be that [ __ ] bad these guys
have been double digit underdogs and not
covering the whole season getting
smoked
and it's only six and a half
i say they don't show up again this week
they dude they go oh they're in
houston uh i liked it in miami oh
they're in miami they're gonna go to
miami paul they're gonna go do some blow
they're gonna bang some broads down the
[ __ ] way they ain't gonna cut that
covering they're not covering
they're not covering
i'm taking the dolphins i'm taking the
dolphins they're mammals paul they
always say don't say squish to fish
all right lace is out lace is out i'm
taking the dolphins
minus six and a half over houston
it's just another manic monday
okay
who do you got i'm going
i'm going my second pick the first time
i've taken this team all year i don't
like this bet gentlemen i [ __ ] love
this bet okay oh okay
i'm taking the new england patriots
first
[ __ ] i was gonna take them god damn
you
i'm i'm taking them minus three and a
half to beat the hapless the hapless
quarterback list
carolina panthers
i left that on the board because you
have not [ __ ] with them all year and i
thought i was gonna you son of a [ __ ] i
thought you were gonna take my thursday
night pick
thursday night paul i'm ripping the
band-aid off
all right oh boy the colts minus 10 and
a half over the jets on the road the
jets won last week that was their
[ __ ] super bowl the colts lost last
week at home to the titans to the
tennessee right to the titans i had that
game i had that game uh that was a pick
them i had the titans i wanted on that
money that game so i'm taking the you
know they got what's his face they're a
quarterback what's it what's his name
there that [ __ ] guy throws the ball
over he's throwing it all over the yard
all right
carson wentz he'll wrap you in the head
with a [ __ ] ratchet i got the colts
minus 10 and a half over the jets on the
road i can't believe you took my [ __ ]
patriots you [ __ ]
now who am i going to take you had first
pick though you could have done that
well paul i i thought you were going to
be all over the chargers you you you
like dude you
i thought you you were on the chargers
[ __ ] train and that turned out to be
a one-night stand you watched one game
against chargers and you were like holy
[ __ ]
this [ __ ] guy i can't remember
anybody's name this week their
quarterback there uh of
chris henship what the [ __ ] his name
the justin herbert justin herbert you
were just like this kid can [ __ ] play
the da da da da i got to get my chargers
thing and quick because they're only up
uh
all right so i got i got i now i got to
pick my last one yeah oh christ this is
like the [ __ ] you know that giant
thing you know where you pull dvds out
at walmart this is my last no you just
picked colts well you can look it up but
yeah paul yeah it's your turn
oh you better all right
[Music]
guys i'm going with
monday night for just another minute i'm
taking
the pittsburgh steelers who are flying
right now three in a row
playing a bear's team that's up and down
at home in pittsburgh monday night
football six and a half tomlins got the
shipwrighted let's go steelers and
they've been winning for me the last
three times i picked them that's why i
hated that game i hate the bears you
don't know who you're gonna get
you know
i'm just stalling people all these games
look [ __ ] terrible jacksonville burst
the bills the bills are going down
three right
three
am i really gonna take the bills given
14 and a half all i got is favorites
here what the [ __ ] i hate that i hate
having a week like that
i want to take the titans against the
the rams but uh henry's out i don't like
that i don't like that at all um
oh gives a [ __ ] paul i'm not catching
you this year [ __ ] it i gotta make a
bold move here i'm taking the buffalo
bills to cover 14 and a half
oh [ __ ] against the jacksonville jaguars
they're losing by like 30 every week
you know what i mean they got that guy
there
what was that [ __ ] toy where the
girls would just brush the hair like
that was the whole toy
barbie oh yeah yeah not barbie it was
like a troll doll or something like that
the guy with the troll doll hair who's
got you know he's got the guy going to
hooters
you know
getting hammered he's got all that money
falling out of his pocket and all these
[ __ ] start backing their ass up onto
him and then it's his the mec guy you
know i thought he was a victim in that
one
yeah i don't know i don't know who that
guy is you know that guy yes paul he he
coached the uh
the team there that was uh the ohio
state
oh yeah i can never remember his name
that was it jim tressel
no no who was the coach of my house
state that that oh
urban meyer is urban meyer still the
coach of jacksonville
yeah
he's literally i love how he went down
there and then became a florida man a
florida man was seen
hammered in a sports bar
um my last pick here
i don't know why this line this is the
most confusing line we've had all year
why the [ __ ] am i missing something
are the san francisco 49ers minus one
against the cardinals
uh that i've only lost one game and
kyler murray is not hurt i don't know
what's going i know jj watt is hurt but
you know what
um i don't know why i didn't see that
game
yeah you're gonna go
arizona that's really weird
i know i know when it really that's when
it's it's like
if they were like three point favorites
you kind of be like okay all right
i'm not [ __ ] with the packers and
chiefs
oh that's gonna kill me to watch them
win easily
i'm gonna take the san francisco 49ers
to win that game i don't know why
i'm gonna take the 49ers minus one it's
basically a pick em in san francisco
i don't know i just feel maybe san
francisco starting to play better maybe
the cardinals
after their first loss who knows let's
let's go let's roll the [ __ ] dice
okay
i don't know i'm not gonna say that that
was [ __ ] up because i don't feel like
singing peggy lee two weeks in a row but
uh i didn't see that one coming i'd
almost be you know what can i switch my
bills bet and i'll take the air just so
we can do a head-to-head i'll take
arizona
i'll take the bills out i'll take
you're crushing me on head to heads damn
it
paul you do you do paul yeah i mean the
moves you're making here paul this year
well we got to do a monday night monday
night special oh let the monday and
that's fantastic it should be said that
uh 2800 people took that bet last week 2
800. that means people who just bet with
mgm saw your faces on the main page and
said i like these guys making america
money and listeners
2 800 people that's [ __ ] awesome and
now we got chicago
pittsburgh
and that's the taco pittsburgh paul i
don't know [ __ ] about these teams and
you you got the hot hand pull you know
and i'm that franchise player paul that
knows if they're not going down i'm
passing the ball what do you got here
you love you're loving pittsburgh the
money line right
i love pittsburgh the money line
so let's do definitely pittsburgh what
about naji harris their star new running
back naji harris going in for a rushing
touchdown
and when is ben roethlisberger you're
not going to throw a touchdown
you don't have to take monday night
football yeah
two you might throw two what do you
think paul
i don't like that's 21 points right
there
yeah um with the bears
who are like sometimes they show up and
they play sometimes they don't but this
is in pittsburgh
who do they have the quarterback brady
quinn
mitch mitchelson
mitch traversky who do they got who are
they no chicago
yeah they got the kid from um
ohio state justin fields
dude i swear to god
this field goal kickers walking down the
street get get recognized more than the
[ __ ] chicago bears quarterback all
the way back to uh
to uh what's his face there jim mcmahon
was the last chicago quarterback that
couldn't walk down the street
so so so we do naji harris gets a
russian touchdown steelers on the money
line and what you want to do big ben
throwing big ben throwing
should we should we make it interesting
how about big ben throwing a pass that
goes more than like 40 you want to do
something like that paul you loved it
down there you can add a four you can
add a fourth thing if you want you could
how about willy galt for a touchdown
who
yeah he's from he's from like 40 years
ago sorry go ahead
um he goes who
he was one of those track stars they're
like you know what
your body works great why don't you play
football you're super fast no one will
catch you
how about this this is a stretch but
tell me if you guys like it
ben roethlisberger throws a touchdown
that goes over 30 yards
is that too much or can they make to
[ __ ] with the odds
can you do that
i think they can i think they could pull
oh you know what [ __ ] it [ __ ] it let's
make people money brothers burger throws
a touchdown naji harris gets a rushing
touchdown and the steelers with the
money lie
yeah i don't want to do like those yards
like that big ben is always like he's
like half bionic at this point at this
point in every season you can add a
fourth bet if you want like you like
maybe you think pittsburgh is going to
get an interception you want to do
something like that a fumble recovery
oof four that's an unpaid point
the steelers get a fumble recovery
that's a ballsy one you want to do that
people make big money though those are
yeah the pittsburgh steelers that's what
they do
let's do that throw that one it's what
it's what are they dolph all four though
still right we're not replacing anything
all four yeah all four all right lovely
you listeners out there if you want to
stop with the first three
paul we hit two monday night specials in
a row
especially with a part
we're meeting the mayor
all right everybody that has been the uh
the bet mgm segment
paul you got to read the outro right
paul reads the outro same as the intro
same as the intro
second verse same as the first
all right guys that's been our uh
week nine of pix hope you guys jump on
with us with the uh that mgm lines um we
are using as you guys know the greatest
greatest uh website to do this is bet
mgm applying to make all of our picks um
and we'll have special offers for our
listeners each week if you haven't
signed up to bet mgm yet use bonus code
burr that's b-u-r-r and you'll get a
hundred dollars free after placing your
first one dollar bet okay here's how it
works you download the vetm gm app and
sign up using bonus code burr that's bur
place your first one dollar money line
bet um any nfl game you'll receive a
hundred dollars in free bets immediately
after placing your bet regardless of the
outcome
okay so it's it's just there go have fun
bet with us just make sure that you use
bonus code burr when you sign up
you have to be 21 years of age or older
to wager in arizona colorado dc iowa
indianapolis michigan minnesota new
jersey nevada pennsylvania tennessee
virginia west virginia or wyoming only
uh new customer offer paid in free bets
visit bet mgm.com for terms and
conditions uh excludes michigan
disassociated persons please gamble
responsibly gambling problem call 1-800
next step for arizona uh
800-522-4700 for colorado dc nevada
wyoming and virginia
800-270-7117 for confidential help
michigan 1-800 gambler indianapolis new
jersey pennsylvania west virginia 1-800
bets off for iowa call or text the
tennessee red line 800-889-9789
for minnesota
uh sports betting is a void in georgia
hawaii ohio and utah and other states uh
were prohibited uh promotional offers
not available in nevada all right and
that's our nfl picks once again tyler
thank you so much for coming on the show
thank you so much for having me this is
a literal dream okay well i absolutely
dreamed about this i i appreciate that
and i am so thankful that you came here
to do your project with us and i hope
we're going to get a second season once
again november 5th roku immoral compass
we'll uh have a great weekend you [ __ ]
enjoy the bonus episode of the thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast and i'll talk to you on
monday
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
the monday morning podcast for monday
november 4th
2013 how you doing how are you
how's it going ah you know i'll [ __ ]
red face is in a good mood this week
huh
you know why because it's hockey season
now i'm [ __ ] with you you know what
it is
the boston red sox
world series champions and i was there
to see it
not in person
i watched it on tv
you know and i got to tell you
all the emotions i had from jumping on
the bandwagon from game one of the
american league divisional series
you know what i realized through
watching all that playoff baseball i
[ __ ] love
hockey
hockey is i'm not even say how great the
[ __ ] game is because i don't want you
guys to watch it because that'll ruin it
and then somehow hockey players will be
wearing pink in october
all right
by the way i'm loving all those stories
that are coming out about how little
money actually goes to breast cancer
research not because i i'm pro-breast
cancer
for you knee-jerk [ __ ] [ __ ] out
there it's just because
from day one if you couldn't see the
money-making
scam that that was and that was also on
the other side to try and get more
female fans
okay if you can't do the [ __ ] math on
that
you know how the rest of it goes
um
so anyways yeah the red sox won it man
it's fantastic hey seattle this is how
the song's supposed to go we
are the champions my friends
i love it you know what the best part
about the [ __ ] red sox winning was
watching was paul verzi immediately sent
me a text and he said congrats and i
knew he didn't mean it
[Music]
and it took about four or five you know
it was it was the red sox parade
something happened and now paul versi
all right a new york yankee fan is now
telling me how arrogant boston sports
fans are i mean i'll listen to that
to anybody else in any other [ __ ]
city but they hear that from a [ __ ]
yankee fan are you kidding me
and then he starts bringing up steroids
a [ __ ] yankee fan
bringing up steroids
you know well you wouldn't know four
manny ramirez he was your mvp with the
[ __ ] steroid really
you ever think maybe manny had to do
steroids because he was facing a roided
up roger clemens a roided up andy pettit
let's go around your infield roid it up
jason giambi roid it up [ __ ] a-rod oh
now we're out to the outfield write it
up gary shetfield
the [ __ ] yankees from the late 90s
right through the 2000s were a [ __ ]
steroid factory
if and a 215 [ __ ] million dollar team
jesus christ
but i don't begrudge them i don't
begrudge them any of their [ __ ]
titles
it was the steroid error
okay you knew what arrow it was if you
weren't doing steroids that's on you
you know
it's like you're in the music business
and it's the late 70s
you don't want to play disco well have a
nice [ __ ] time
playing in front of eight people
with your gregorian chant or whatever
the [ __ ] it is you want to do it was
this steroid error
i'll tell you right now we're all going
to [ __ ] be on them they're gradually
gradually going to become legal and all
of this [ __ ] that everybody's talking
about come on look at these [ __ ] guys
you know
i love all these guys how they get hurt
later on in their careers and then they
go to germany and they like i don't know
what they're doing over in germany but
god knows those [ __ ] maniacs love
experimenting on human beings these
people are coming back the peyton
manning's the [ __ ]
kobe you kobe's going to come back made
out of titanium and they're going to
give all the credit that the drive the
determination the competitiveness this
guy has to to to retire from such an
injury i'm telling you right now
if you want to rewind the clock and come
back like [ __ ] lee majors in the six
million dollar man you go to [ __ ]
germany i don't know what the [ __ ]
they're doing over there
i had a buddy of mine recently was
talking about that they take blood out
of here and they're [ __ ] spinning
around in this [ __ ] centrifuge oh is
that what they're doing
give me a [ __ ] break
my [ __ ] leg is killing me because i
ran like two feet down the street the
other day at 45 years of age these guys
can play tackle football until 40. i
know i'm not a professional athlete but
i am a human being
all right
i'm not gonna name any [ __ ] names but
there's a lot of people dude when i was
a kid
35 was the breaking point and when you
were 37 you were [ __ ] ancient
people weren't even
chess players could continue on at 37
golfers
but that was it
you you were [ __ ] dust
it was over these [ __ ] guys you know
they'll blow out their knee at
41.42 and come back a year later and
have a career [ __ ] year
what did it take us like what a couple
hundred thousand years to walk upright
all of a sudden the knee has evolved
that far in [ __ ] 15 years
i don't know what i'm talking about but
i'm just saying all right
oh my god dude versi i have never seen
him whine
he's so [ __ ] pissed that they're
calling boston title town i mean what
else are you gonna call boston
three super bowls three world series an
nba title got [ __ ] out of another one
with those corrupt refs but whatever
we'll give it to him yeah yeah whatever
game seven call 35 fouls on us and 16 on
the other team that's fine that's good
let's watch him win it from the line um
and a stanley cup championship they've
won eight [ __ ] titles in 10 years
with only four teams
the entire state of new york at this
point there's what those are ten [ __ ]
teams
new york city next year when the
islanders move there they're going to
have two hockey teams two basketball
teams two football teams two baseball
teams and they've never had a 10-year
run like this the [ __ ] green bay
packers if green bay wisconsin could be
considered title town in the 60s with
one [ __ ] team
you know
yeah i'd say we earned it i'm not saying
that throughout all of sports history
boston is title town but right now the
last 10 [ __ ] years
be honest with yourself get past your
hatred
of [ __ ] boston just look at it on
paper
who would you rather be you
and the success your team had
or or what happened in boston
i had nothing to do with it
i'm not being arrogant i'm just stating
the [ __ ] facts
all right and the fact is
i was watching game
was what the [ __ ] game six
and at one point you know they're
changing out goddamn pictures and it's
taken for [ __ ] ever and i click over
to watch a little bit of the bruins
penguins game
and uh it was right when they had a
fight right off the face-off in the uh
the third period i forget the guy in the
penguin's name uh name of the guy in the
penguins he's [ __ ] hilarious he's in
the middle of the fight and he's sitting
there smiling looking in the other
direction staying out of the way of the
bruins guys rights
you know you can tell uh there's a lot
of new bruins this year and i i've been
watching baseball so i got to get caught
up and it was just instantly
the fight was over and then we watched
like two minutes of the game
and um
i [ __ ] i'm gonna say it that game was
more exciting the game six of the world
series
maybe it's just me how i'm wired
hockey's it's i watched the replay of
the the the bruins i taped a bunch of
bruins games and i'm getting caught up i
watched the bruins islanders game
and that was a ridiculously [ __ ]
exciting game
jesus christ thomas vanek does that guy
[ __ ] own the bruins or what he's
killing us i got i'm gonna try to make
it out by the way to an islanders game
before they close that place down i'd
like to do that and also go to a 49ers
game i got it i mean i've been to both
places but uh
it is the last year i haven't been to
nassau coliseum i think i went there in
88 or 89.
i can't and i went to a islanders
rangers game i know i talked about this
before but uh that's a legendary
building and
i think it's sad
that they're leaving and they're going
to go to brooklyn are they going to be
the brooklyn islanders
i don't know i like i i've always liked
the islanders every except for when they
beat the bruins in the uh when the [ __ ]
did they beat us
maybe 83 no 83 be choked to the
canadians
somewhere in there we met them in the
playoffs and i thought we were gonna
have a run there it was during their
their dynasty
um oh by the way i saw some [ __ ]
[ __ ] red sox fan it said 2004 2007
red sox dynasty
[Laughter]
who the [ __ ]
taught like like
the definition of a dynasty i swear to
god is like it's just going
somebody has to stop it from its
freefall i remember when the
patriots we won three in four years and
it was called the dynasty and that was
the first time i'm like wait a minute
where dynasty has always been you have
to win three in a row
two in a row is a repeat three is a
dynasty and then like however long you
can make that go
and as far as i know
my knowledge in professional sports
i think the record in hockey and
baseball is both five
by the yankees and the canadians of
course and
and then let's see in basketball it's
the celtics with nine
which i mean
i don't know i mean it's like literally
the beginning of the nba i look at a lot
of that [ __ ]
um you know
those championships you win in the 23
skadoo years when the [ __ ] league is
just getting started
you know like the league is so new that
if you just walked in with a microphone
in a pa system you would be the team's
[ __ ]
announcer during the game you know those
old guys 80 year old guys when they talk
about you know how did you get your
start
you know announcing for the uh milwaukee
bucks well i i you know i saw the paper
that they had a game and i came down
with a microphone
and that was about it
for 50 years later you know
like now it's just so
it's so locked down so there is that
weird thing
and it's also uh that's a weird thing
about sports where like
each sport has that team that just went
on that [ __ ] run
when
the [ __ ] was just getting established
and they got so out in front
that no one can oh is that really right
i don't know the lakers caught the
celtics which i are catching up to them
that i think is the most impressive
thing because they did it from 1970 on
which is basically
the free agent era and all that so
that's the most impressive one
canadians and uh maple leafs went blow
for blow until 67.
the celtics are a good example of it
and um
and the yankees to a little bit of an
extent
you know it's like they won a ton before
you know
anybody other than white guys were
allowed to play but
um you can't [ __ ] with going from ruth
to garrig to dimaggio to mantle like no
one will ever
[ __ ] although
although the pittsburgh penguins
they're halfway there
now i would just i guess i wouldn't say
that
dude they went mario lemieux yarmouth
yaga
to gino and [ __ ] sydney crosby that's
pretty impressive
in this day and age in a 20-year period
you know peyton manning to andrew luck
it's just not that you know what it's
too early
it's too early to look back i don't know
i don't know what what the [ __ ] am i
talking about this is the monday morning
podcast everybody and uh
uh what did i do this i had a [ __ ]
great week i'm back out on the road this
week and i'm doing a tune-up show
tonight at flappers
out in burbank
i gotta make sure i give everybody uh
their money's worth this weekend because
coming up i got uh
arguably the biggest week of shows i've
ever had i'm at constitution hall
in uh washington dc and for you comedy
nerds like myself that's where eddie
murphy taped delirious and i believe
martin lawrence also taped a special
there so
uh i got to bring the a game for that
one
um and then the next night i'm at the
beacon theater
and then the last night i'm at um
i'm in upper darby people keep saying
stop saying it's philly i mean to me
it's 15 minutes from downtown philly
upper darby whatever the [ __ ] you want
to call it uh i'm at the tower theater
and i'll be bringing along
the most bitter sports fan that i know
in this moment right now
paul verzie
dude he was so [ __ ] mad
that the red sox won he even brought up
the celtics
their pylon championship
okay in 2008 which i've always admitted
to and i felt that kevin garnett trade
should have been investigated
considering kevin mchale was like the
[ __ ]
whatever was running [ __ ] for the
timberwolves
okay and i'll listen like once again
i'll listen to anybody giving me [ __ ]
about that other than a [ __ ] new
yorker
he's going to give me [ __ ] about buying
a new yorker is going to give me [ __ ]
about buying a [ __ ] championship
really 77 78 oakland a's slash [ __ ]
new york yankees the 1994 edmonton
oilers slash new york rangers give me a
[ __ ] break and then i don't even need
to bring up the yankees
99 2000 2009 get the [ __ ] out of here
[ __ ] jerk off
um
anyways
what am i talking about here uh yeah i
had a i had an unreal we i got i got to
do a little bit of advertising here
sorry i'm a little bit all over over the
place i gotta
i get some [ __ ] i have to do today
before i run over to the club um i did a
benefit last night for uh
for pit bulls
um down at largo
and i gotta admit i was a little [ __ ]
out of sorts i've been in a weird mood
i've just been enjoying i've been home
for like two weeks for the first two
straight weeks in a row this year and i
got to tell you i did not miss going on
the road kind of scared me
you know
sat around making pumpkin bread and [ __ ]
wearing a [ __ ] apron
the hell's wrong with me i gotta get
back out on the road i'm gonna retire uh
dollar shave club everybody
um this is this this one right here is
uh this is killing it right here
everybody loves this anybody with
whiskers
be you a [ __ ] male or a hairy woman
this one is for you dollar shave club
for a couple of bucks a month
dollarshaveclub.com delivers amazing
quality razors right to your door not
only does it save you a ton of cash but
it saves you from trudging to the
drugstore for a pack of blades i always
get stuck behind the lady paying for all
her loose change from the car ashtray
is that me supposed to be saying that no
i don't i usually get stuck behind the
family of seven who want to develop
pictures get some ice cream and also uh
i don't know buy some listerman
listerman listerine i don't know what
the [ __ ] it is um it's like she thinks
exact change is a requirement
um anyways but with uh dollar shave club
for just a couple of bucks a month
amazing quality razor blades they're
delivered right to your door people
that's right no more wasting time and no
more getting up uh getting hit for 20
bucks every time you buy razors
everybody here is getting their dollar
shave club blades and you should too i
should really look at these before they
send
these to me okay it's not everybody here
it's me
it's just me all right
me my split personality um all right
here's a genius idea try replacing your
old shaving cream with dr carver's easy
shave butter butter from
dollarshaveclub.com trust me your face
will thank you later i've used that
stuff it's great uh don't waste time at
the drugstore behind the lady with
paying in pennies go to
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash burr
or go to billboard.com and click on the
dollar shave club banner keep your
stress level low and your bank account
balance high shave shave time shave
money with dollarshaveclub.com
all right there we go evoice
if you are an entrepreneur hey who isn't
two things keep you up at night
increasing revenue and controlling
expenses
e-voice is a simple technology that
helps you do both
how do you do that well i'll tell you
let's start with revenue e-voice helps
you make sure that everyone who calls
your business is treated like gold you
get your own toll feel toll-free or
local number you can set up a dial
jesus christ bill you can set up a dial
by name directory or have calls
instantly routed anywhere your cell
phone your house your partner or
assistant or all of the above e-voice
even transcribes your voicemails and
emails them to you so you can prioritize
when and how you want to respond without
interrupting your workflow with e-voice
you can never leave money on the table
just go to the podcast page at
billboard.com and click on the e-voice
banner or go to e-voice dot com slash
billbar e-voice also cuts your expenses
by acting as your business phone system
and your receptionist this technology
could save your business hundreds of
thousands of dollars evoice starts out
at only 10 bucks per month
um with that you can get plus that i'm
sorry plus you can get a free 30-day
trial right now when you go to the
podcast page page at billboard.com and
click on the e-voice banner or
go to evoice.com billboard that's my
website billboard.com and click on the
e-voice banner or go to evoice.com
bilbar all right
let me just try reading slower in
enunciating let me see if this helps me
hulu plus
hulu plus everyone you've probably tried
hulu.com
now with hulu plus you can watch your
favorite shows anytime anywhere
hulu plus lets you watch thousands of
hit shows and a selection of acclaimed
movies on your television or on the go
with your smartphone or tablet and guess
what it all streams in hd for the best
viewing experience with hulu plus you
can watch your favorite current tv shows
like snl community and family guy you
can also check out exclusive content
including hulu originals like the
awesomes starring snl seth meyers and
moonboy starring chris o'dowd from
bridesmaids hulu plus also offers a
great selection of acclaimed films for
only 7.99 a month you can stream as many
tv shows and movies as you want wherever
you want right now you can try hulu plus
free for two weeks when you go to hulu
plus dot com slash bill that's a special
offer for my listeners make sure you use
huluplus.com
so you get the extended free trial and
then and also they'll know that we sent
you go to huluplus.com bill now or click
the hulu plus banner on the podcast page
at billboard.com all righty
back to the podcast
all right here's one that i've been uh
keeping an eye on
over the last couple oh by the way dude
i tried another i'm you know i've been
sober here for [ __ ] 13 days
um
i like it i like it in the morning i
hate it at night in the morning i want
to hug somebody but at night i uh
you know i don't know what i want to do
but i want to inflict pain on somebody
so i've just been trying to fill up
those times with some
that i used to boos
uh and i'm not done forever people i'm
coming back all right
just like mariana rivera i'm coming back
um
i tried you know i tried to make
homemade ravioli for the first time
okay and like an [ __ ]
rather than just trying to make the
homemade ravioli and making a simple
ricotta filling
just keeping it simple like that or
maybe just making a sketti
right
what does old billy [ __ ] do he tries
to make a braised short rib ravioli
with this mushroom gravy on top it was
like trying to make three [ __ ]
entrees
by myself
i already knew how to make braised short
ribs so i had to go through that whole
[ __ ] process just to get the filling
for the ravioli that i had never made
so for the first time in my life
my mother bought me one of those
kitchenaid mixes
like seven years ago and i have never
used it
the [ __ ] thing weighs more than the
goddamn stanley cup
and i finally took this thing out of the
back
of my poor excuse for a pantry and i set
it down and i had the pasta making uh
attachment
and i i can't even tell you how [ __ ]
excited i was
so i watched a sicilian woman
i'll send you the link to it where she
makes uh she makes this homemade pasta
semolina with her [ __ ]
perfect
just you just look at her she's she's
she's from sicily it's not like she's
sicilian and she's lived over here for a
couple of i'll just show it to you when
you look at her fred sanford [ __ ]
hands you know that she's been needing
pasta dough since the day she came out
of the womb and she knew what the [ __ ]
she was doing so the the pot the dough
actually came out all right i probably
should have needed it a little bit more
but i didn't have that um
the ravioli thing where you it's like
you you're like a notary republic and
you got to stamp it down so i make the
[ __ ]
i make the [ __ ] ravioli
it actually came out really good i could
have mixed it a little bit more there
was a little bit of
granulated
semolina so i kind of [ __ ] it up a
little bit and then i put my filling in
there
caramelized onions with braised short
ribs and a little bit of carrots in
there
[ __ ] delicious sticking in this [ __ ]
and i go to make these things and i
[ __ ] up on two levels one i didn't
seal them correctly and two i made them
too big
because i guess when you drop them in
the water when they're done is when they
float but mine was so big they were like
[ __ ] barges and they were just
floating up top and they weren't sealed
and all the [ __ ]
all the [ __ ]
filling came out of him
in him it was a [ __ ] mess
it was an absolute [ __ ] mess and
i almost started crying it took me like
that entire process
took about five and a half hours it took
me three hours
to [ __ ] braise the short ribs get all
the ingredients braise the short ribs in
a [ __ ] dutch oven
and it just i i i didn't you know what i
didn't waste a day you learned something
in your failures i know how to
caramelize onion i know how to [ __ ]
reduce that goddamn sauce down to a
[ __ ] gravy and the douche bag with
the youtube video the way you edited the
[ __ ] together you made it seem like that
took five minutes so i sort of already
started sauteing my mushrooms you [ __ ]
and you [ __ ] left half of the
ingredients off of your [ __ ] because you
won that cooking contest with it all
right and i get it you want to be a
celebrity chef so you don't want to tell
all your [ __ ] secrets so why don't
you put up a recipe of pb and j next
time instead of having this vague thing
and having me waste my whole [ __ ]
saturday you cunk i'll forget it all
right
so anyways
but a homemade pasta not that hard to do
i'm going to do it again tonight picking
myself up off the mat unlike george
foreman when my league got knocked him
down back in the day right i'm getting
up
i'm coming out
i'm going to try spaghetti tonight
making it nice and simple
all right i got a prego sauce i don't
give a [ __ ] i'm keeping i'm working at
one working on my pasta game tonight
and that'll be easy i got the attachment
you just you know
send it through number one a couple of
times and then two then up to three i
think and then i'll put the [ __ ]
sketti attachment on and i'll send it
right through the [ __ ] and that's
gonna be it that's what i'm hoping
jesus christ what happened to me you
know what happened i stopped drinking
that's what happened when i stopped
drinking
all right the booze goes away and the
apron comes out of the drawer
oh hey by the way do you know we didn't
celebrate halloween this year
i was really uh that was nia's call
because of all the uh
all the [ __ ] [ __ ] who came to our
house last year who were well beyond the
age of being able to trick or treat so
instead we went to the uh clippers
warriors game
and uh what a [ __ ] team the warriors
have man
i'm actually uh
thinking about getting the [ __ ] nba
package because i don't watch enough
sports right
um
it was ridiculous the [ __ ] game was
like
it was like an all-star game as far as
the uh it wasn't like 120 something to
120 something
um
but i can tell you we went to the game
and being stoned sober at a game
and just taking in the level of mouth
breathing [ __ ] drunk morons that go
to the game
that was really eye-opening
um
i just was sitting there like wow that
that guy is me
except i'm sober right now
i watch this drunk fat couple in front
of me get hammered out of their minds
and then order this big thing and nachos
and then feed them to each other like
this like they were in lady in the [ __ ]
it's one of the most disgusting things
i've ever seen but like
if i was hammered i would have been
looking oh look they're in love
so i'm basically i'm gonna try and stay
sober until uh
until i go over to europe and then all
bets are off
all bets i mean like i'm gonna go to
italy and i'm not gonna [ __ ] drink
some wine
give me a [ __ ] break right
anyways and speaking over there in
europe
this is a story that i've been keeping
up on
is the uh the greenpeace 30.
the greenpeace sturdy okay now for those
of you who haven't been paying and
paying attention or or uh haven't
listened to the podcast really quickly
it was a group of 28 greenpeacers is
that the correct word greenpeace people
and uh
and two journalists
and they decided that they were gonna
board
a russian oil rig
by basically somehow shooting their
ropes up there and climbing up
the side of it and they got arrested by
russian navy seals and they were charged
with piracy as you would think that they
would
and they've all been you know all the
greenpeace supporters and their family
members they're all outraged
thinking that the russians are
overreacting
and uh and when we last saw them
let me click on this
when we last saw them they were in a
jail in murmansk russia
which at this time of year it's dark 24
hours
and uh
and they were actually going to drop the
piracy charges from piracy down to
hooliganism
but uh this is what's happened this week
arctic 30 being moved from merman's to
saint petersburg st petersburg is out of
the arctic circle and now you're
basically just south of finland
um
and i want to say that that's the city
that
finland had to give
back to the russians even though they
beat him in world war ii they had to
give him back just because they sided
with uh
uh
angry charlie chaplin over there um all
right amsterdam november 1st 2013
greenpeace international
understands
uh from diplomatic sources that the 30
men and women detained in russia
following a peaceful protest that's what
they said peaceful protest
like that there was nothing peaceful
about that it was somewhere
between peaceful and an act of war
as far as i'm concerned you just don't
go out into international waters
and just
without permission board somebody else's
vehicle
you can't do [ __ ] like that
all right
but they consider it a peaceful protest
uh against an arctic oil platform and
are being moved from a detention center
in mermanx to a jail in saint petersburg
you like how they completely ignore the
fact that they tried to board the
[ __ ] thing it's not like they just
showed up and kind of drove around it
with signs saying hey man [ __ ] knock
it off
um lawyers for greenpeace are not aware
of the reasons for the move greenpeace
international executive director of
kumi naidoo said uh that's the detainees
this is what the this kumi person said
the detainees shouldn't be in jail at
all
they should be free to join their
families and restart their lives saint
petersburg has some daylight in the
winter months unlike merman's families
and counts and consular officials will
now find it easy to visit the 30 but
there is no guarantee that conditions
inside the new detention center will be
any better than in merman's in fact they
could be worse there is no justice
there's no justification whatsoever to
keep the arctic 30 in prison for for a
day longer i love how they just
completely ignored that they they
broke the law
i don't know what law it is
i'm completely uninformed but i know you
just can't go around boarding other
countries [ __ ] oil i wouldn't even do
that to exxons
and they're allegedly on my team
anyways they are prisoners of conscience
who acted out of determination to
protect us all and they should be free
now that i don't disagree with but the
way you [ __ ] went about it
um
so here's the thing greenpeace today
released photographs blah blah
so as of last week they they allegedly
dropped the piracy charges
but um
i guess they're saying they haven't now
all they've done is tacked on hooligan
charges so they then now stand
as of right now they now stand accused
of both offenses
which carry a maximum sentence of 15
years for piracy and seven years for
hooliganism respectively all right so
i don't know
i don't disagree
with greenpeace or that type of thing
but i hope that they learned that you
know you can't just go around
boarding russian oil platforms
and just because you know it's a
peaceful
i mean jesus christ i mean that that's
like
i don't know somewhere in there there's
a protest there's that gray area between
a protest and an act of war like that
[ __ ] that's going on between china and
japan right now they're fighting over
those islands
i forget who said somebody's gonna shoot
down another person's drones
and uh the other country's gonna
consider it a [ __ ] act of war if they
do it
i gotta tell you man that that will be
[ __ ] insane if japan and china go at
it
who do you like who do you like in that
dog fight
let's just say for once the united
states stays out of it and russia stays
out of it
and if the two of them were just gonna
throw down i would just think sheer
numbers
china has to have them they gotta have
you know and those islands are closer to
china so that's more home-field
advantage for them
i don't know
is it weird that i want to see it
that's [ __ ] up right
i'm just sick of like you know it's like
when the yankees and red sox played each
other like to the point they just they
pat each other play each other for 30
years i got burned out in that rivalry i
just wanted to watch somebody else i
started watching the royals
i'm sick of watching the [ __ ] in the u.s
go at it with everybody i want to watch
japan i want to watch two other
countries have a nice
[ __ ] throw down
i want to see it pay-per-view japan
versus china who do you like
you know technicians versus [ __ ]
smash mouth football
all right enough with me sounding
[ __ ] stupid trying to talk about
international [ __ ]
i had a dream come true this week
everybody
aside from watching
just paul versi
oh my god was he a [ __ ] baby
he was pulling out all the stops last
night he
[ __ ] hates boston and then he tried
to tell me all the reasons why he loved
boston to justify his hatred of boston
you know he basically gave me the sports
analogy of the classic no no no wait my
best friend is african-american that's
what he did but he did it in a sports
you know
it was [ __ ] horrific i think the
people are funny i like the food shut
the f stop trying to give yourself
credibility
um
please please listen to the paul varsity
uh podcast the versi effect this week
i'm sure he's going to be going off if
you're as a red sox fan you should
really listen to them you got to listen
to them piss and moan about their beards
and all of that [ __ ] it's going to be
it's just going to be [ __ ]
music
to my goddamn ears and all he does is he
just brings up the fact that the giants
beat the patriots twice i don't give a
[ __ ]
we still won three super bowls
i would rather who would you rather
[ __ ] be
and i'm not giving all new york fans
[ __ ] i'm just talking specifically to
versi
um anybody else there who's a whiny
[ __ ] [ __ ] who god knows i'm a
hypocrite because i've been a whiny [ __ ]
about the lakers and the yankees and
every the canadians it's just fun to be
on the other side of the whining
um and now i get to act like i'm a
[ __ ] perfect person
um yeah i am a hypocrite go [ __ ]
yourself i stand by it anyways the other
dream they had come true is i've been
i've been gradually uh for like i would
say i don't know whenever mike johnston
started doing those drum lessons
whenever i stumbled upon him i was still
living in new york i believe when i
first found him back in like 07 or
whatever
and um you know i found these drum
lessons online and i just kept going
from guy to got a guy and then i stopped
at this guy mike johnston and he was
just head and shoulders
above everybody else that i saw out
there and and the
stuff that he was teaching
and the way he broke it down
and his whole philosophy the whole
pattern speed movement the whole [ __ ]
thing that he did was just
i don't know it just really connected
with me
so for years i was thinking you know
some point i'm going to see that guy
either at a clinic and i'm going to take
you know maybe take a lesson one of the
other blah blah blah blah
long story short he came down to the new
recess studios in santa ana california
which is right down in uh
um orange county california if you're
playing a band and you don't want to
play in some grimy horrific rehearsal
space like most of them are
with like [ __ ] stains in the rug
from grand funk railroad 40 [ __ ]
years earlier when they weren't even
famous
uh if you want to play in
just state of the art awesome facility
recess studios in santa ana
california anyways long story short i
guess the guy who opened the place was
one of mike johnston's drum students and
he was talking about opening a rehearsal
place and mike said well if you ever
open one i'll come down for free and do
a drum clinic so that's how i ended up
going down there
and i reached out to mike and he goes
hey why don't you come down and take a
[ __ ] lesson he didn't say [ __ ]
he's much more classier god than i am
and i got to knock that out
and uh it was the [ __ ]
so i'm sober i'm cooking and i took uh
drum lessons
from a [ __ ] drum god
this week
and now i have to go back to [ __ ] lax
tomorrow
where somebody shot up a [ __ ] tsa
agent
[Laughter]
and i have been a grumpy [ __ ] on stage
my last two shows
i'm getting nervous everybody i think
i'm getting old and i'm getting too old
to do the [ __ ] road i gotta i get you
know what i got to go to germany
like peyton manning and those guys i
need i need to [ __ ] get up
have them spin my blood around some
centrifuge or whatever the [ __ ] you call
it but uh anyways i'm getting off track
so thank you to mike johnston
unbelievably patient
uh
dealing with my drummond and helping me
try and improve
and if you know if you play drums or
whatever i highly recommend going to uh
mikeslessons.com
and um
he's just state of the art you can skype
in and watch the guy
you know do live lessons it's just like
he is at the forefront of all of that
and on top of all of that he's a
phenomenal drummer
and we'll break down any basically if
you can get in touch with him anything
that he did he'll break it down as slow
as you want he's just
he's the [ __ ] so that was my week and
with that
let me uh
let me um
oh and also something else i'm not going
to say who it was but uh someone else i
know
uh has one of those those cars uh teslas
and i got to drive one and ride in one
it was the fastest [ __ ] car i've ever
been in it's a hundred percent electric
so all you guys who wrote all that
homophobic [ __ ] about my prius know that
my prius is actually a gas combustion
engine past five miles an hour it's a
big [ __ ] scam it's only electric from
under five
and uh five miles an hour and under but
this was actually a full-on electric car
and it was [ __ ] insane
the back of my head was tingling i think
that was blood going to the back of my
head we got up to 60 miles an hour so
god damn fast
and he didn't even have the fast one
he had i guess the slower version of it
and uh
you can drive from san diego all the way
up
to the border of canada
and charge the car right now it takes 30
minutes to charge it you can go 350
miles
most of the charges i guess are in rest
areas so you just sit down you have
something to eat check your [ __ ]
messages i know it's 30 minutes but
whatever you pull into a gas station you
get a slim gym you go in there you take
a [ __ ] right that's 10 minutes
you know what the one thing i didn't ask
was how much
the electricity costs
i have no idea but i guess uh their goal
is you're going to be able to hopefully
by 2014
drive from um
los angeles to new york city
but uh i don't know if you got the money
because they're not cheap dude it was
insane i wanted to i guess all the
batteries are under the car and i wanted
to look under and see them and the guy
was like well it's going to look like a
skateboard underneath the car
and uh
it was insane there was a couple things
that he said and i forgot to ask he said
there's no fluid in the car
and i'm thinking all right well it's all
batteries so you don't need to uh
you don't need any antifreeze you don't
need any oil
there's no transmission no transmission
fluid but i forgot to ask about the
braking system you gotta have brake
fluid right you know it's funny as i
could just probably look it up but uh if
you get a chance
definitely check those things out
and um this guy was telling me that
there's people at drag strips that'll
take like to some guy he has a datsun
just a regular old datsun from the 70s
it's all electric power and he [ __ ]
wins in the quarter-mile drag races all
the time all the
all the time which makes me feel great
because for years i defended the prius
and electrical power
by saying you can get on a subway and
that can move a thousand people
at like 35 40 miles an hour
during rush hour in new york city you
think a [ __ ] car if they really
wanted to make one
with electrical power couldn't be fast
well i finally experienced it so uh
i don't know i'm really babbling this
week
uh let's let's get to the uh
let's get the questions for this week uh
pumpkin bread hey billy crocker
tell us something exciting about the
pumpkin bread making experience
as if you were doing sportscenter
coverage of what went down during the
process
dude what is this like a [ __ ] improv
class
i don't know
i don't know what to tell you i already
told you about the disaster
i might you know what i did i already
did it with my my
bray short rib ravioli that was like
talking about the red sox collapse in
september last year that's as close as
i'm gonna get
and uh i don't know we gotta we're gonna
switch it up this week with a bunch of
uh international emails
take a break from the relationship
advice
listen to this one this one's from peru
dear billy holliday
i am from peru and i love your comedy i
wish i could say peru loves you but i
haven't met many people who have heard
of you i think you should come and
perform here well what the [ __ ]
too
if you i'm to you why don't you just
have a birthday party and i'll fly down
there
take me to a soccer game
and i'll do stand-up and i'll bomb in
front of all your relatives
um as they stare at me and my lack of
pigment anyways nobody knows me down
there but for some reason i should go
there and perform he says but i don't
know how many people would understand
your humor
he said he said a gold digging [ __ ]
would be a good thing here because it
would mean she gave out sex
and also what's so bad about a girl who
digs digs for gold
that's been that's better than a girl
that doesn't
you know i forgot you guys actually have
minds down there and that's actually a
job
you know for an individual rather than a
giant machine
uh anyways he says that's what people
here would think don't feel bad though
because i think the most people here
don't know who bill cosby is
listen
if i somehow could get through rosetta
stone spanish
and uh learn how to speak your language
if you think i wouldn't come down to
peru
i'd actually would read up i mean do you
guys hate us down there too
i really don't feel like getting
kidnapped by some sort of rebel group
and i hate to admit it but to me that's
what a lot of south america is because
that's what i see
i see all the you know
killing pablo i read that book i
probably i probably haven't read a lot
of good things about south america
yeah
it's cocaine cowboys
it's uh nazi war criminals
it's um
the most perfect asses in the world in
brazil
and uh
i don't know
i don't know what else it is
it's the galapagos islands
that's arrested abroad it's the hand of
god
soccer move by that [ __ ] guy
was it vince ferragamo
i don't know a lot about down there i'd
love to go though
you know if i could go down there and
you could guarantee that i wouldn't get
kidnapped i wouldn't get stabbed because
of some horrific [ __ ] that we do in our
foreign policy down there i would
definitely go down there i've been to
costa rica that's the closest i ever got
to uh
to south america but um that is on my
bucket list at some point i want to go
to all the continents other than
antarctica
i don't i have no reason to [ __ ] go
there all right anyways
let me know you guys open an
english-speaking comedy club down there
i'll i'll fly down there that's a
promise all right from dublin
all right there billy red boy
uh big fan blah blah blah i only
recently found out about your podcast
and been listening to them instead of
the depressing [ __ ] that's played on our
radio station dude the difference in
work my work days from listening to your
comedy and laughing my ass off in the
car is immense the urge to punch some of
my managers i have to deal with on a
daily basis that turn has turned from a
vein popper to just saying go [ __ ]
yourself in my head and laughing in
their faces so thank you for that and
keep it up can't wait for the dublin gig
i've got tickets and i'm going
to bring a date so it's going to be a
great night thanks for penciling us in
on your tour
i'll buy you a pint
in vicar street go [ __ ] yourself all
right that was just sort of a love
letter there's really no advice there
uh well now that you brought it up
i got to do my i got to give you my
dates here
for the big european tour
when i fall off the wagon
oh i'm going to fall off hard when i'm
over there
i already got some drinking buddies in
england that i met the last time i was
over there and one other friend
that's coming down from uh scotland so
right there
you know how that's gonna go down
uh where the hell are we shows bang
right there
uh the first one
december 4th glasgow scotland
december 5th
i'm in amsterdam december 7th i'm at the
forum in london for three shows oh wait
i'm sorry december 8th
i mean also at the forum in london so
one of those nights i'm doing two shows
three total
december 9th
i'm at vicar street
uh dublin ireland december 10th i'm at
the savoy theater in helsinki finland
two shows december 11th i'm at the
bremen theater in copenhagen denmark
on december 12th
i can't even read the name in oslo
norway the f
the folky t
teteret foca teteret i don't know what
the [ __ ] that is
i'm at the circus in stockholm sweden on
december 13th and on december 15th
i'm at
the silverberg hall
in reykjavik reykjavik however you say
iceland
there you go
and i'm going to be boozing it up flying
solo
i usually travel with the lovely nia but
uh
she's done that run with me a number of
times she's a trooper i mean you can see
that's just like a uh that is definitely
a thrash
but um she's coming with me to italy
we're gonna have a good time over there
and then i'm flying off and she's gonna
stay in italy
with some friends
his daddy goes out and makes some
[ __ ] money all right that's how it
works
um all right
let's get back to do the final uh
advertising reads here all right
legalzoom everyone legalzoom there are
two reasons why now is the perfect time
to start your business reason number one
the economy is picking up and the longer
you wait the longer you delay your
potential success reason two right now
you can incorporate your business or
form an llc at legalzoom.com for just 99
legalzooms online process guides you
step by step and you can get total
customer support they couldn't make it
much easier legalzoom provides self-help
services at your specific direction and
can connect you to an attorney but they
are not a law firm so save a pile of
money
oh so you save a pile of money get an
extra discount when you enter burr in
the referral box at checkout don't wait
on the sidelines while others are taking
charge of their futures now is the best
time to get in the game and launch your
business
don't put this off for incorporation
trademarks patents and more just go to
legalzoom.com right now discount code
burr that's legalzoom.com discount
discount code burr stamps.com everyone
the classic
here we go stamps.com
think about how many hours you've had to
waste
think about how many hours you've had
to waste going to the post office for
business for your business driving there
parking waiting for the next available
clerk there's nothing i can do to get
those hours back for you but i can save
you time moving forward with stamps.com
stance.com brings all the services of
the us postal service right to your desk
24 7. buy and print official us postage
using your own computer and printer
stamps.com will send you a digital scale
and it instantly calculates the exact
postage for any letter or package any
class of mail there's no guesswork it's
easy then just hand your mail to the
mailman and you'll never waste time at
the post office ever again i use
stamps.com to send out all my dvds
my posters whatever the hell it is i'm
trying to get to the thing
the gig or whatever if i can use it if a
[ __ ] like me can figure it out then god
knows you can too right now use my last
name burr for this special offer no risk
trial plus 110 bonus offer that includes
the digital scale and up to 55 free
postage don't wait go to stamps.com
before you do anything else click on the
microphone at the top of the page
of the homepage and type in bur bur that
stamps dot com enter bur and finally
vista print
what is vistaprint you ask yourself you
know it's a business card
that says a lot about you and your
business
um
what this copy makes no sense
let me start over again i'm just going
to read it the way they wrote it take
two
vistaprint a business card says a lot
about you and your business are you a
hard-working landscaper a hip and funky
salon owner a loyal dog walker no matter
what you are or what kind of business
you have vistaprint.com has thousands of
designs to just say what you want and
today we just got word of a great offer
on their business cards get 250 of their
premium cards for only 10 bucks
um the shipping is is on them too
good lord 10 bucks for 250 business
cards christ they're giving it away i
created my cards the other no i didn't
stop putting words in my mouth i didn't
create any cards but i'm going to
because it's only 250 a month it's a
great lin it's a great
deal i don't need to lie
vista prince has so many designs to
choose from that you that you're born to
find that you're bound to find one of
these
that says just what you want
um
once you find the card you like design
the process itself it's easy and it's
fun add text photos or logos and you can
change colors fonts and move things
around so again that's 250 high quality
business premium cards with shipping
included for only 10 bucks
go to www.this
vistaprint.com click on the heard of us
on radio tv button in the upper right
hand corner and put in the promotional
code bird
good lord as you check out
make sure you take a look at the other
marketing products they offer like
postcards flyers brochures and websites
they can even match your business card
get 250 premium business cards for only
10 bucks including the shipping just go
to
www.vistaprint.com click on the
click on the heard of us i give up click
on the heard of us tv radio button in
the upper right hand corner and put in
the promotional code burr you know what
i'm gonna hire somebody to read these
things for me
all right
somebody with a nice sexy [ __ ] voice
and i'll be i'll be equal opportunity
male female straight gay we we got to do
something about these reads okay i can't
read them and now they're trying to do
this this phony put in a personal
touch
like i'm using all of these
products okay i i believe in all of
these products but i don't use all of
them
all right i'm only one man i can't use
everything out there
all right here we go let's get back
to the reads for this week what are we
up to 53 excruciating minutes
military origin story billy boy
i am a military vet and wanted to share
a story with you seeing as you like
military history
i'm by no means an expert this is
probably all [ __ ] but this is how
the legend goes i love our i already
love how this story starts
um your whole setup of this is what 99
of the [ __ ] that comes out of my mouth
can be defined as
i'm no expert and this is probably
[ __ ] but this is my opinion because
i overheard this
from somebody in a mall
uh back in vietnam there was a guy named
colonel robin olds
who was
who was commander of a fighter squadron
he was a triple ace
i don't know what that means
does that mean he killed three people or
fought in three wars or had three
different ways of killing you in the air
i have no idea but he was a triple a's
i'm going to use that next time i'm
drinking in a bar
some woman gives me [ __ ] i'll be i'll
have you know i'm a triple a's what does
that mean you figure it out
uh he was a triple a's and fought in
world war ii and would later retire as a
general
good lord
any one of those things is beyond
anything i've accomplished in my entire
life uh olds grew a mustache while
overseas in defiance of the air force
regulations all right he's a red sock
you hear that versi
and he's a triple ace we are the
champions olds grew a mustache while
overseas in defiance of the air force
regulations
um and command
and commit and commanded his men to grow
one too on the basis that it makes you
bulletproof
one of his men refused to do so because
he he felt it looked [ __ ] and got
shot down
he was recovered and grew a mustache and
wasn't shot down again
before this is this why all these studly
guys throughout the years would always
have [ __ ] mustaches
before hipsters ruined them
um before
before this guy went home he shaved his
mustache and got shot down a second time
it is now a tradition for flyers to grow
mustaches overseas it's such a
superstition that schedulers will make
sure at least one on the crew has a
mustache and avoid making
uh
as a mustache and avoid oh and they
avoid making all female crews well what
about tom cruise he didn't have a
mustache but goose did
and goose did he got hit by the canopy
well that's hollywood that's not real
war
all right this grew into the tradition
of mustache march in the air force where
everyone regardless of whether they fly
or not gross mustaches this in turn
evolved into
movember where men grow mustaches or no
shave november where men grow beers to
raise awareness for prostate cancer
and other male cancer
and associated charities during the
month of november
so go grow a mustache you pasty freckled
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
thanks for the free laughs
um i will look i i'm aware of prostate
cancer all right
i guess i should grow one so i never get
it i've grown mustaches in the
i'm a contrarian i can never go the
[ __ ] way that's actually a really
interesting story i hope even eight
percent of that was true
by the way who was this guy who got shot
down
that's where it all falls apart and then
when there was a guy
that's that's how most of the urban
myths start but i like it
great story
and i stand by your complete lack of
research because that's everything that
i do
all right from finland
we're going around uh going around
europe here from finland uh hello there
william f burr i'm a 22 year old guy
from
finland and i've waited a long time for
you to do a show here
so i'm very excited to hear you're
coming to helsinki in december
unfortunately because of my studies i'm
doing a practical tr i'm doing a
practical training in africa for three
months so i'm going to miss the show i
hope i will one day have the money to
come see your show in the u.s
so i'm going to ghana in a group of four
students and i'm the only guy in the
group i'll be in the same house and
going to the same workplace with these
three ladies
for three months
we all know each other quite well but
i'm mostly used to hanging with guys so
if you give me some advice or tips
on how to mentally prepare for these
three months it would be greatly
appreciated
are there some topics or actions i
should make
sure to avoid thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself ps love the podcast
uh and all that other stuff hope to see
more in tv ah that's very nice of you
what a nice email um are there some
topics listen dude the amount of things
i've [ __ ] up with women all i can tell
you is what not to do
um
all right this is what i would do if i
was you
the first thing you got to do is if
you're a type a male on any level
you got to tone that [ __ ] down
oh if you're angry
all anger does
is scare women
okay or makes them not want to be around
you or it makes
women who have daddy issues
uh
you know
it's like a moth to a [ __ ] light
except the moth reaches in grabs your
heart pulls it out of your chest and
throws it down the stairs um
if you're gonna live with these three
women
all right this is what you could do
are you trying to [ __ ] these women or
are you just trying to get along with
them
all right first things first uh
make sure you're really neat
granted you know women in the bathroom
are some of the messiest [ __ ] on the
planet
but i would do that i would come with
slumber party energy
and just [ __ ] giving to their [ __ ]
conversations
okay and that's right there is where you
establish cr credibility you're not
angry you keep your part of the bathroom
clean and you come with oh my god you
guys
you [ __ ] given to that [ __ ] energy
late at night when they want to snack in
their [ __ ] jam jams you join them
all right
and you never try to [ __ ] any of them
then what you do is you talk to them
about how you're having problems meeting
women in ghana
and you need advice and then they'll
become a [ __ ] wingman for you
and you'll be crushing [ __ ] ghana
nice [ __ ] ass whatever the hell you
want to call it
right and left when you're out there and
they'll actually help you do it
that's that's that would be my game plan
but the last thing
you should do is try to hook up with any
one of them unless it's the last weekend
the last weekend comes around all bets
are off you get in there and you [ __ ]
them all
[Music]
somewhere in there is probably some
information that you could use if
anybody has any suggestions on what this
guy should be doing my uh my trip isn't
until
december
if anybody else has studied abroad with
three broads
and has better advice
for the love of god let me know and i'll
pass it on to this this uh
this uh this this this
fine young gentleman
all right documentaries
uh just a bill on capitol hill ah one of
my favorites i know a lot of you guys
are too old to remember schoolhouse rock
do you remember that i'm just a bill yes
i'm only a bill
and i'm sitting here on capitol hill
[Music]
that was way too long
pray that i will but today i'm still
just a bill um
hey your top school house rocks
uh three is a magic number
conjunction junction
verb that's what's happening
i'm just a bill's a great one
number nine
he's a great one
oh my god i'm gonna have to [ __ ]
upload that [ __ ] i have that on
cd box set somewhere
ah jesus under some championship hat
rubbing it in all right i've got two
documentaries for you you red-faced
um
to lock onto
all right first up blackfish this is
about killer whales in sea world
basically it starts from the time they
got a killer whale into cap
into captivity
uh i really apologize for my reading out
loud this is like the worst i've ever
done
um
anyways he says
this is about
basically it starts from the first time
they got a killer whale into cap
captivity at sea world they separated
from its mother at the age of two males
remain with their mothers their whole
lives so the separation is very
traumatic
they are kept in tanks too small and fed
very little the whole thing is
mind-blowing it aired on cnn and i
recommend it to everyone you won't
believe the stuff that comes out of the
sea world employees mouse
oh though i i might just take
your uh your word on that i i can't
handle watching people do stuff
uh
animals and kids
and uh
and then the next level right like the
level of rage
because that's about as innocent as it
gets and then the next level of rage
above that is is someone you know
beating the [ __ ] out of their girlfriend
and their wife or anything like
i can't handle watching that stuff like
they made that thing was at the cove
where they just drive all those dolphins
into that little area and then they just
bludgeon them to death like just tell me
where i need to donate money
i i really can't watch like last night
this is my second time doing that pit
bull thing and one of the pit the
woman who organizes it has a has a
pitbull herself and has a scar on its
back or some douchebag dump battery acid
on the thing and uh
i showed up late to it this year hoping
i avoided the story
because i knew that someone was going to
ask and i showed up and someone asked
and i had to listen to it again and it
just [ __ ]
i swear to god i could literally kill
somebody i don't know if i could do that
but i could do some horrific blow torch
[ __ ] to them
um so
i'll watch as much as that as i can
if it's on netflix i'll try and pull it
up uh second dirty wars this follows a
lone journalist who tracks the origins
of a drone strike from afghanistan
to yemen
it's streaming on netflix oh i'll watch
this those drones fascinate the [ __ ] out
of me
uh if this aired on network television
there would be riots in the streets over
what our military is doing in the name
of the u.s
all right but i'm also going to watch it
knowing that this is i mean is this is
this a documentary or is this like one
of those michael moore documentaries
where it's really an op-ed piece
um
i'll watch it
i'll watch it [ __ ] it
uh dirty war dirty wars correlates with
the news coming out about obama claiming
to be good at killing people to his
aides
here's an article from yahoo i'll give
you guys this link
i'm not co-signing on any of this [ __ ]
until i see it
jesus man do you have a happy one in
there
is there one about an old lady making
her old her own jam
and uh beating out the corporations
you got to give me a little you got to
give me a ray of sun i appreciate all of
that stuff i might have to watch dirty
wars
i'm gonna i know i'm gonna have to i'm
gonna watch both of those [ __ ] it
jesus christ
hey how about now that he's given me two
that's going to make me lose
even more faith in humanity
and uh and i'm not saying i'm better
than these people i'm a complete piece
of [ __ ] myself
but uh can i get it can i get a good one
in there
uh does anybody have a documentary on
iceland standing up to the bankers that
i could watch
because that one fascinates me
um
and how that wasn't covered
that much here in the states i would
love to see that one um
all right so here's the wrap up
everybody now that the show is over
don't forget to sign up for your free
trial of hulu plus hulu plus lets you
binge on thousands of hit shows anytime
anywhere on your tv pc smartphone or
tablet uh and that's it for the podcast
this week
um i had just an awesome week
i know i was just bandwagon but it's
really you know exciting after all those
years of watching
the red sox suck to actually watch them
now
consistently be this winning franchise
and be able to turn stuff around and i
know they spend more money than god
uh
but it is cool and um
i don't know i i hope it happens
to your city i hope you guys go on a run
especially cleveland
kansas city
um all of those you know i'm i don't i
am oh i'm only a hater of uh
you know the yankees
the canadians and the lakers and even
then i respect all of those teams as
much as i give them [ __ ] i definitely
respect them but uh i don't even hate
the giants i actually love the giants
and
i'm hoping that they uh
i don't know i i just i don't i don't
have that thing in football where i have
like a team that's the yankees
i mean i love that the jets
beat the saints this week
because that means that uh
old foot fella foot fetish guy down
there i'm forgetting his [ __ ] name
rex ryan he has a chance of keeping his
job
you know
i don't want him on espn
analyzing
football games i want him to as a
patriots fan i want him right where he
is
head coach of the new york jets
all right that is the podcast for this
week congratulations to the 2013 red sox
i wish i watched all
throughout the year but i didn't i'm
just a bandwagon guy and i'm going to
wear the red sox championship hat and
i'm going to laugh when you guys give me
[ __ ] because i am bandwagon however i am
die hard bruins patriots and i'm
actually going to get the nba channel
because uh package because because the
celtics are rebuilding
and um i want us i want to see if they
can do it again
they can rise from the ashes
and buy some more free agents and see
what happens but um i actually you know
went to that clippers warriors game and
i had a great time and the warriors
looked like a really exciting team as to
do the clippers so
yeah [ __ ] it
what do i do [ __ ] up the ravioli again
this week i'll watch some hoop
all right that's it hey by the way uh
i'm gonna be at the rangers penguins
game
all right
stone sober
madison square garden this week
should be a great game all right if
you're not watching hockey you're
missing out go [ __ ] yourselves i'll talk
to you next week